Good googly Mowgli,
ladies and gentlemen.
Uh,
this episode of the podcast is brought to you by untuckit.com this is a new
sponsor and it's a new sponsor has come up with a novel idea.
Everybody likes wearing those button up shirts.
Like I was wearing a flannel shirt earlier today.
Everybody likes wearing them,
but if you don't tuck them in,
they look kind of odd,
right?
There's like this little blanket that goes over your Dick and your butt.
It's like a backwards hill.
Yeah.
Like the idea is that you're moving around a lot,
so when you talk it,
it keeps it from untied.
But who the fuck talks their shirt in?
Especially if you don't have a job where you have to Tuck your shirt in and like
if you're a banker,
he can't be wandering around what your shirt untucked.
I'm not going to trust you with my cash,
but you don't even remember the last time I tuck my shirt in.
I hate it that much.
Well,
you're,
you know,
you have a unconditioned unconventional job if you're a dude with a conventional
job.
Like if you,
uh,
you know,
I thought you were to say body,
but it's,
that's why I don't like the cut.
Tuck it in.
I don't want to look like a fucking grapefruit.
It's uncomfortable though being tucked.
He got you guys,
you know,
there's no,
not much space.
That's the thing that guys would go guts do when they have their pants tucked
into and the gut is like firm and tight against their pants.
Almost like a,
a bra for their gut when it's tucked in it in.
Yeah.
The way I,
that shit.
Right.
Yeah.
It's not a comfortable,
I'm much more comfortable with,
with shirts untucked,
but then there was always that extra cloth.
Well this company untuck it decided to figure that out.
They,
it's made exclusively for men who wear their shirts untucked.
See,
know women won't be so excited to wear your clothes either.
That's another good thing cause one of the reasons why women like it because it
covers they've of JJ and their butt and they can walk around with their legs or
legs hanging out more skin.
This will definitely show more skin,
but you know,
it's,
it's going to show your whole vagina.
Let's be honest.
Look,
look at this guy's penis says,
that's crazy right there.
So it'd be less likely that chicks will a wear your clothes or if they do wear
their clothes,
they would have to wear underwear.
I feel like if I saw this guy in the street,
I wouldn't even notice anything different going on.
You know,
it just blends right in.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the brand ambassador is this guy,
Brad Richards,
who's a hockey star and he,
uh,
he decided to be a part of the company as well.
It's because it's a novel and great idea.
Untuck it has solved the problem,
ladies and gentlemen made exclusively,
as I said,
for men who wear their shirts untucked.
And women too,
you can wear it,
especially if you're,
you know,
tend to be like more of a manly sort of a woman,
which is nothing wrong with that.
Okay.
Fucking wear flannel.
Who gives a shit man where whatever you want,
if you're hot,
by the way,
you could pull off Flan on.
Nobody gives a shit.
Uh,
so anyway,
use the code,
Rogan,
R,
O,
g,
a,
N for a special 10% discount@untuckit.com.
That's U,
N t,
U C K,
I t.com shirts designed to be worn untucked.
Use the code word Rogan and save 10% shipping is free both ways,
both ways I guess.
Like if you'd want to send it back,
uh,
the right shirt can make all the difference.
So,
uh,
go check it out.
untuckit.com we're also brought to you by Squarespace,
Squarespace,
the very best way for you to create your own professional looking website.
Nothing but rave reviews by the way of Squarespace,
uh,
of all our sponsors,
it's one of the most popular and it's just,
it just works great.
And it's something that's,
it's such a,
just a godsend.
It used to be,
it was so difficult to get a website used to have to hire someone and that
person was probably busy as shit and it takes massive man hours.
The man hours had been significantly reduced.
And you can make an awesome professional website,
including with an online store,
super easy to do.
You can sell digital downloads like standup comedy or music or anything along
those lines.
Um,
beautiful designs,
drag and drop content.
Super easy to use,
about as easy as attaching a photograph to an email.
If you can do that,
you can figure out how to do this.
My site,
my site is built on Squarespace.
How powerful that is on box.
If you want to bring it up.
I've got a store on there as well.
I'm by P.
Dot com built on Squarespace.
Can you believe that?
Ladies and gentlemen,
what are the odds?
We didn't plan this.
Alan,
what do you need to know?
What more do you need to know?
Plants started at eight bucks a month,
including a free domain name.
If you sign up for a year,
responsive design,
your site would look awesome on any device and commerce on the online stores.
Every site comes with an online store.
Squarespace has a logo creator as well.
We can create a clean,
simple logo designed for yourself in minutes.
Many,
many of our friends use Squarespace.
Um,
Duncan Trussell uses it.
Tom Sager and Christina Pezeshki don't tell you is it?
I don't know.
I know I built Chrysler new shops,
death squad store on that recently.
Yeah.
Brian uses it.
Kara Santa Maria uses it as so many people use it and there's
looking at,
you got seat so you can plug in on the front page there,
you can plug in your Instagram feed.
So that's always fresh content.
So,
uh,
if you're a person like me and the majority of what you do is on youtube or on
social networks and you don't want to constantly be updating a website,
one way to keep it current is to use this Instagram plugin,
which feeds right back to your Instagram feed obviously.
And so gives people a reason to come back and check it out.
Maybe they don't use Instagram themselves.
They can still see what you're up to.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
Oh,
go back.
Look,
I had the hemp force on this.
See,
that's what I left with last time.
And now I'm on,
you know,
I'm hooked up.
I'm on the program now.
And uh,
unbox therapy
b.com is the website.
If you want to go and check out Louis's awesome website.
Great reviews on all sorts of different types of electronics and items and,
and homemade craft brew.
How's that crap beer thing?
That good that that was sent to me,
but I don't actually have it,
so I would just try it.
Try it again.
That's a great idea though.
I have a craft brew thing and your house definitely.
This is actually cool here too.
Well,
this uh,
is all the different items and stuff that I use that are in my,
uh,
personal inventory of items that help make my videos possible.
Oh,
nice and beautiful.
That's cool.
And it's a plugin.
They linked back to the Amazon store like ick.
Squarespace makes doing super complicated things.
Incredibly easy to do.
Boom.
There you go,
ladies and gentlemen.
So go to squarespace.com uh,
and get 10% off and a free trial for your first purchase.
Go to squarespace.com enter the code word Joe.
That's for a free trial and 10% off your first purchase.
squarespace.com enter in the code word Joe Squarespace.
A better web starts with your website.
That's their logo.
That's the shit that they say.
Everything else is like basically my own words.
But a better web starts with your website.
That's them.
It could be worse.
It could be way worse.
Could be way worse.
All right.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] Dot Com it's o.
N.
I.
T.
We dosed up Louis the last time he was here and he had a dream that he was
hanging out with Brian Singer basically.
Plus the protein stuff kept me full.
You know what I mean?
I was,
uh,
about to start editing a video.
I took a big protein shake and I'm not super healthy or anything like that,
but I stayed full for a long time.
I didn't want to get up.
I didn't want to snack.
I'm telling you,
I'm gonna take this shit seriously.
Like the pro I've had people recently complained about the hem forest.
They don't like the way it tastes,
which is,
I dunno,
I guess it's subjective.
I just,
for the record,
I always mixed mine with coconut water.
I love chocolate though.
Chocolate's good.
Yeah.
Well,
it's also made with Stevia.
So it has very little sugar,
one gram of naturally occurring sugar per serving if you're interested in hemp.
And especially like people said like why is it so expensive are hamp is the best
hemp you can buy.
If you go to any store,
you can buy hemp protein powder and you can compare the two of them between this
and hemp force.
And there's two,
two differences.
One,
the percentage of protein per serving is much higher on the stuff that we buy
and we just bought the best stuff that you can get.
It's not cheap.
We have to buy it from Canada to unfortunately they're starting to change that
law.
They're fighting against it.
They're going all the way to the supreme court.
And in Kentucky there was like some recent website,
there was a detailing Kentucky's battle to uh,
to grow hemp,
which is non psychoactive,
by the way.
Completely nonsense not getting anybody.
Hi.
It's just connected to from the beginning to marijuana.
And the reason being that marijuana became illegal,
and this is really wacky stuff,
but it was because of hemp hemp,
the commodity hamp being used for paper,
hemp being used for cloth hemp being used for food and for oil.
Henry Ford in fact made the very first fenders of his very first car out of
hemp.
And there's a video online.
If you go to that video that you could see Henry Ford banging on the fender with
a hammer.
Hemp is a crazy plan.
I mean is literally like,
it comes from another planet.
It's so different than anything else.
If you pick up a hemp stalk,
it's light,
but really hard,
like a piece of hemp stalk,
like a big thick of a,
a hemp tree that grew a thick and large.
It's amazing how strong it is.
It's weird.
It's like an alien plant you can eat.
It has all the essential fatty acids.
The protein in it is very,
very digestible.
Um,
like I said with with on it,
we try to use the best stuff available,
but you can buy hemp force or hemp protein rather.
That's a cheaper variety from many different sources and you can see the
difference.
You can see it and it will be more gritty.
Um,
it won't digest is easily prob probably,
and it probably won't have as much protein per percentage,
but it's all good.
I mean,
look,
any hemp protein is one of the best proteins you can get.
Um,
it's just,
it hasn't,
you're going to have less issues digesting it then you will way some people have
no problem with way other people are more sensitive.
My wife has waiver had whey protein prior to this one showing up and we were
comparing the nutritional values and something I noticed on the hemp was the
fiber,
the fiber compared to the way,
well it's plant based.
It's like 11 grams or something.
Yeah.
And you know,
I could have,
I could use the help everybody get fiber.
It's just good for your body.
Um,
anyway,
we carry that in a host of other healthy snacks and foods like the warrior
protein bar,
which is a,
a,
a bar that's made out of Buffalo.
Uh,
it's made out of buffalo in this ancient native American tradition that uses
cranberries and pepper with no antibiotics,
no added hormones,
no nitrates,
and a totally gluten free,
although I don't know why he would have gluten.
I guess you could maybe put wheat somehow or another than a bar to make it
anyway.
Um,
what these bars are,
is essentially just a really healthy protein snack that's totally natural.
Buffalo meat,
14 grams of protein,
and it's based on a recipe that has been in the Lakota Sioux warriors for
century really can't call them Lakota.
Sioux Lakota is what they call themselves.
Sue is with other,
other Indians would call them,
other native Americans would call them.
And Sue means it means enemy.
So calling them Lakota Sioux Warriors,
it's not really the correct verbiage.
Wow.
It's a Lakota people anyway.
The LAKOTA people,
they figured out a way,
you know,
many,
many years ago to how to preserve meat without a,
all the modern shit that we use that it was probably super bad for you.
So no MSG,
no lactose,
no nitrates as I said,
which is the one thing that people really,
uh,
are very leery about when it comes to,
um,
uh,
food supplements,
not food supplement,
food,
snacks like a beef jerkys and Salamis and things like that.
Things with nitrates,
hot dogs,
nitrates,
not so good,
no antibiotics as well,
no added hormones,
all just super healthy.
And again,
14 grams per servings and only 140 calories.
A just one of the many things that we have it on it.
Uh,
and also if you use the codeword Rogan,
you will save 10% off any and all supplements.
Anything else before we get
cracking?
Y'All got anything on that?
Next weekend.
We're going to be at the Comic Con America American Comedy Company,
a Wednesday and Thursday,
July 23rd and 24th bringing kill Tony Thunderpussy and having a comedy show
there with Bert Kreischer.
Glorious Ladies and gentlemen.
Go to death squad.tv for all of that information and a next Saturday night or
next Friday night.
I am with Tony Hinchcliffe.
We are in San
jose@thecenterfortheperformingartsandalltheinformationforthatisthatjoerogan.net
under tour.
Our right fuckers Lewis from unbox therapy's here.
We're all hopped up on coffee and speed and all kinds of shit.
Let's just do this.
Okay.
Pitch out Rogan experience.
Try by day Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Louis.
A lot of people don't want to think you're on speed when you're on coffee,
but you're aligning yourself.
Ladies and gentlemen,
you're in a mild form of speed.
That's a good point.
Drugs are everywhere.
You don't like a doctor.
Carl Hart said,
you don't want a drug free America.
That's an unproductive Martha,
right?
So I'll go with it.
With that coffee away from people.
They're not working anymore.
It's amazing,
isn't it?
Remember when you were young and there was no Starbucks,
they didn't exist.
Like this is something like that waiting for us out there.
The zero,
like a new thing that's going to just,
you know,
that's a good question.
Some substance I was coffee was there forever,
right?
Marijuana before.
Yeah.
That's probably,
yeah,
it's capital yet.
Isn't that what's happening in Colorado?
Oh yeah.
It's happening like crazy.
Right?
Carl Rogers going off Washington state's going off now too.
Cause now they just started selling it.
So now the same ripple effect.
The same effect it's happening in Colorado,
which is they're making way more money than they even planned.
Right.
They had like an idea of how much money they would make and they're making way
more,
way more now.
I mean,
well that's something that has been tied up for,
for too long.
I think.
It makes a lot of sense.
Fascinating.
What a strange world we live in.
You know,
I mean now they have a,
have you seen the pot coin?
It is a digital currency based on marijuana.
I get inevitable.
You gotta be able to buy marijuana with his digital currency.
I think you need your own currency next.
That's when that's when the government comes after you.
You got to stay low.
Jre Coin,
you got to stay free and the unambitious that's true.
I know.
Running for office,
no,
trying to affect policy.
Nothing crazy.
But maybe coins can become that seriously.
Like where communities online could have a coin almost as a reward system for
the best participants within that community.
Well,
I think ultimately we will have digital currency across the board for a variety
of different things and it can be really easy for communities,
whether it's online communities or towns to set up their own money.
Because I remember there was a town and man,
I want to say like North Carolina,
but there was a town that was in the news while back where,
um,
they had decided to make their own digital,
not digital currency but local currency.
And it was being talked about in the news and it was like everybody sort of
agreed what things would be worth and they would all have their own,
you know,
way of trading goods and selling things and passing it back and forth to each
other.
I see that,
yeah.
That like as an online thing
be everywhere.
Yeah.
It is the decentralization of the power,
you know,
why should some person in Missouri be concerned with what guys on Wall Street
are doing?
You know?
Yeah.
Like what,
why,
how,
why is that affecting you?
Why are you allowing it to affect you,
I guess?
Does it have to be all international like this?
I don't know this,
there's smarter people than me,
that that's probably something to say about that,
but the,
when the bailout happened,
right?
That was the conversation.
It was,
you know,
dudes in suits taking money away from
dudes and plaid shirts.
Do you know Michael Shermer is,
no.
Was He famous skeptic?
Was he on the podcast?
No.
Oh,
you guys.
Okay.
He's a famous skeptic.
He wrote this very strange article for scientific America that's been chewed
apart.
And,
uh,
it's,
it's interesting because it's like his idea of a,
if you like Google,
Michael Shermer Scientific America,
he apparently writes a,
a an article there and he's got this myth of income inequality is like the title
of the article.
And look,
this is how I know your ideas about finance or dumb.
If I think they're dumb,
this is how I know because I'm clearly dumb.
That's the litmus test.
If I read your dumb shit and I'm like,
Yo,
this is some dumb shit that that's when you know that your shit is off.
It's really strange.
It's a weird analysis of the,
um,
of the situation and uh,
the idea that here's,
here's like one quote,
almost all of our studies participants,
the authors conclude grossly underestimated Americans,
average household incomes and overestimated the level of income inequality.
So both income inequality and social mobility though not as ideal as we would
like them to be in the land of equal opportunity or not as large and in mobile
as most of us perceive them,
he's getting destroyed in the,
yeah,
whenever I see something like that,
I always wonder if it's the audience dictating the message or the message being
authentic because I always wonder who are the people reading this magazine?
They're probably fairly well off,
right?
[inaudible] scientific,
American American or whatever.
So aren't you?
Isn't it easier to reinforce what they want to hear then it is to start stir
something up?
I don't know,
but when I've read this,
this is when I read something that's so goofy like this.
This is obviously like a libertarian slant.
You know,
there's a lot of people that they,
they,
they lean libertarian and libertarian almost has like a bit of a conservative
context to it or a conservative bend to it because it's a lot of that things are
not as bad as everyone is perceiving.
Pull yourself up by your bootstraps.
The ability to,
you know,
to have more freedom will equal more,
less regulation and more freedom will equal more prosperity.
It's online,
it's an ideology.
It's an ideology as much as being a conservative is as much as being a liberal
is like sometimes people that get on that one team and then they just sort of
adopt the ideas and the inclinations.
Right.
Team.
So this seems like what he's doing,
and this is again coming from Warren,
this seems like a very libertarian in its slant and it just,
whenever someone does something like this,
I,
it makes me question like all the things that they think about,
like you're supposed to be a guy who points out logical fallacies.
He's involved in critical thinking,
objective reasoning and you say something like this.
It's like,
no,
there's,
there's crazy inequality in this country.
I mean that's the night that is insane.
That's exactly what I was going to say is I think the separation between rich
and poor is such an obvious thing.
I mean,
how can you dispute it?
I watched,
I can't remember the name of the documentary right now,
but it followed a couple of people,
silicon valley type a entrepreneurs and tracked their incomes relative to those
of individuals within the company and the sort of ratio over time,
how those,
how those have changed.
But if you look at technology,
which is sort of the,
the angle that I'm looking at it from,
the whole intent more often than not is to build in efficient,
like build efficiencies into your process.
So if you're Amazon,
for example,
figure out a way to run your warehouse without people.
Figure out what figured out a way to have robots do to automate all of it,
right?
Because essentially your bottom line is affected by how much you cannot like,
like the automakers for example,
get robots in there that,
you know,
their technologies appears to push in this direction of eliminating humans from
the equation where it becomes tougher to pinpoint where the actual value is
being added in,
in the product that you're receiving.
So it's not like Amazon warehouses don't have humans in them.
They do and they're creating jobs and they can go around and say,
we open a new warehouse,
so we hired 200 people or whatever it might be,
but once upon a time without the automation,
how many people would that have been?
Yeah.
And what is going to happen
then when they,
I mean,
are they really testing drones for delivery?
That's not bullshit.
I,
that's not bullshit.
I mean it's not,
I think it's not nearly as close as the video makes it seem,
but just the idea that there's the idea,
the idea that it's not,
it's going to happen.
It's like when they first made those photographs where you put the hood on and
you stood up there and don't,
oh,
they had that thing and like was it like 1850 or something like that?
Yeah.
The time between that and having it in your pocket was inevitable.
It's definitely,
all those ideas are out there.
Someone just has to them.
Definitely.
So once we have drones that there are testing that a delivering products,
it's a matter of time before the skies are filled with robot delivery trucks
that are,
they're landing places and dropping off
TV's.
And definitely I think the last time we were here we're talking about self
driving cars and how it,
like in an airplane it's okay for that process to be automated.
But in cars we freak out about it.
He said he didn't think it's the same thing with drones.
People are afraid of what they don't know,
afraid of the unknown.
But maybe drones are a little bit further out.
But what's happening right now is also interesting and exciting and it's kind of
flying under the radar in the sense that you're,
you have a Amazon prime,
you have Amazon fresh,
you have all these ways of getting things that you need without necessarily the
same,
uh,
the same ecosystem,
the same same chain that you once would have had where you had a delivery man
brings it to a store and then the person in the store puts it on the shelf and
then you have to go to the store to buy it and you have to go through a cashier
instead of an automated checkout.
Just a number of human beings involved in that process used to be a lot more,
so everybody in that value chain could take a little piece for themselves.
But in this Amazon universe,
it's all about eliminating those cogs and just doing a to B.
So yeah,
a drone is maybe the end game,
but even right now,
there's a huge impact to that,
that form of consumption.
Yeah,
it's,
it's so strange to wash the climate shift and change and it's so strange to
watch just online shopping.
Remember I,
I did some online shopping a year ago.
I mean not a year ago.
A while ago rather.
And um,
I forget what it was that I bought,
but somebody said,
where'd you get that?
I said,
I got online and he was like,
Oh man,
I wouldn't buy anything online.
Put your credit card out there.
That's how long ago was that?
Long time ago.
Okay.
Yeah,
I mean,
um,
I was on when,
when online shopping first existed,
I was buying things.
I was just like,
this is so crazy.
So cool.
You could find something online then shows up in your,
I think that,
um,
now it's almost more common to shop online than it is to not shop online.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know why mom still,
I would never put my credit card on there and my mom's not like super old,
but I think that word,
we just do it.
So we think everyone does well and it depends on the item as well.
What percentage?
Let's take a guess.
What percentage of Americans shop on?
I'd say
60% Oh,
that actually do it at all frequently.
Frequently?
I'd say 50 to 60% what's free?
What's frequently?
Once a week.
First of all,
if you tied once a month,
if you type in what percentage of Americans,
the first question is are gay,
what does that tell you about people using Google search?
What percentage of Americans are gay is first?
What percentage are Christians?
Second though?
Is that really that strange if you think about it,
yes.
Do you have the answer to that question?
The gay part?
Yeah.
How close?
How close would we ask everyone's gay.
Even
enough time?
Yeah.
Everyone's gay.
You just need enough time.
I'm just curious what that top till the search is a common search.
I'm just curious what the top result actually is.
No.
Wikipedia.
What do you think based on your own findings?
Like the people I see in America,
so I don't have enough experience with all of America.
Just humans.
Canada.
You,
you guys are American north?
No,
I know,
but I'm saying,
I'm talking more about urban urban areas versus rural areas,
royals,
they're all gay.
All those farmers are as fuck.
They might not even know.
That's what I'm talking about.
Like I have,
I have city experience.
I don't have any country experience.
Do you think it's different?
I think they hide anymore.
In fact,
the city country thing is more defining than than say the city.
You come from.
Like people say,
oh,
somebody from Chicago is like this and somebody from New York is like that.
In fact,
I've,
I've been in marketing meetings where they have specific terms for those urban
type of people.
And you're talking about black folk?
No,
no,
no.
Not Eric got Canadian.
No,
not urban like that.
But I mean,
I mean the life
experience of a person who lives in a high rise versus the type of person who
has a few acres.
It's a totally different life experience.
And therefore the culture that you participate in is going to be a little bit
different.
So when people say to me,
for example,
Oh,
you know,
you're Canadian,
you been to Toronto a lot,
so you know,
it's roughly the same kind of idea.
But when you ask me a question like that,
statistically I would say Toronto was probably more like New York then New York
is like Kansas City.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
I agree with you on that.
Except folks.
Well,
the,
the big difference between Canadians and Americans is how nice everybody is this
way.
More nice people for whatever reason he thinks of urban centers.
Yeah,
I know.
I noticed people say,
excuse me in,
sorry a lot
more that has me,
sorry.
Pardon me.
High doing smiling smile.
It's just a friendlier place that happens.
I feel like it's probably because you don't have this background of Congress,
you know,
it's a different beast.
It's a different kind of mentality that set up the country.
Yeah.
Where's the America is definitely different culture for sure.
Definitely close it.
Oh Yay.
Take a little bit twisted,
sort of,
you know,
and again,
it varies depending on where you are,
but one of the,
one of the things that comes up more than anything has guns,
gun,
the gun,
the difference in the perception of gun crime,
et Cetera.
That conversation always comes up when I'm talking to,
you know,
people from America that asking me what the differences and that,
uh,
famously that Michael Moore documentary,
what the hell?
Which one was it?
His one of his first ones.
But bowling for Columbine.
Was it bowling?
Bowling for Columbine?
Yeah.
Where he,
he's from Michigan and he went over the border to Windsor from Detroit.
And I don't know,
he had some statistics in there and people weren't locking their doors in
Windsor.
And I don't know,
he had a lot of people thought that that was hard.
She thought it was horse shit too.
But he trying to draw some
kind of conclusion there that even though we're culturally identical,
we don't shoot each other,
which obviously is not true,
but some of the statistics coming out of Chicago right now are crazy as far as
the amount of people that are dying due to gang warfare,
et cetera.
Like there's nothing like that at all.
So I don't know.
There isn't like that in Canada.
No,
no.
I think Toronto,
I don't want to say a number because I don't know,
but murder figures,
I mean it's one of the safest and Rob Ford think I've kept you guys to say,
but doing all your crack.
That's what he does is spin it off the street strategy.
Hanging out with the thugs.
Yeah.
He was trying to calm everybody down towards overweight white people.
Is that the prince,
that book about,
I don't remember,
but a king needs to be down with the people.
You see the minute he gets up on his high horse up on a hill somewhere to go for
crack,
he can't relate anymore.
That's what I'm saying.
For New up under a Free Rob Ford.
That's what I say.
I think he's running again.
He's running a porn star actually.
Perfect.
The world's gonna.
Yup.
It's fucking late.
Perfect.
Nikki Benz.
That's the perfect kind of way to look at politics is that if,
if these people can be there and nothing actually happens,
there's no actual effective.
It,
it,
it for me it exposes politics as a whole.
Well,
politics given the state of our culture,
I think the most intelligent,
most capable people don't want that job.
I decided no,
I'll just get some puppet and place to do my bidding and pay them off or you
know,
it's obviously not that planned out.
It's like one guy's pulling strength scores,
but therefore most people,
they don't want a job that doesn't pay that well.
It's going to take a shit load of your time and uh,
everyone's going to hate you no matter what you do.
Yeah.
What,
who wants that job?
That's smart.
I mean,
that's the problem.
we have real issues.
All right.
It's saying actually the Americas,
uh,
there's,
there's several different articles about shopping online,
what the numbers were,
but it's overtaking stores.
It's saying now 40% 47% of consumers said the internet would be their favorite
shopping destination.
Wow.
Yeah.
Here's in 2013 it says more than 80% of the online population has used the
internet to purchase something.
So at least once,
and that's the only people that have used the internet.
So that of all,
I'd probably say it'd be lower.
I'd probably say like 60 globally.
Like,
yeah,
there's something we don't have access.
Like how about how many people shop on their phone?
What would you say?
They're all that's growing rapidly.
I know that for a fact,
uh,
I don't know the number seven out of 10 smartphone owners will use their
smartphone for holiday shopping.
Wow.
Finding store locations and checking,
comparing prices being the top two uses with 45% of the consumers saying they
use social media to assist them with their holiday shopping.
Definitely fascinating.
I think social media is a huge,
huge,
huge factor in buying electronics.
Huge mean,
we're talking your friend Marcus Marquez,
Marquez who uh,
also has a videos online.
Great.
Really in detail videos about cell phones especially.
He's helped me a lot of,
I really enjoyed his videos that I was talking to him about it.
I was like,
there's never been a thing like this before.
No.
And they uh,
they actually,
we were involved in some report recently.
Uh,
it was at some university report.
Um,
I'm not remembering the name,
but they did some tallying to figure out how many people watch videos like that
prior to making a purchasing decision.
The percentage in,
in our world,
in the tech space,
it's huge.
One,
the,
the numbers were staggering and so this is really awkward thing going on right
now where the influencers are becoming the retailers in a way.
We're taking on that role where it used to be a guy in a blue shirt at best buy
who could give a shit about the job,
who you kind of had to deal with whatever information he had,
you didn't have a choice.
And now it's like,
why would we,
it's not very,
it's not the best use of resources to take a bunch of unsophisticated
individuals with a part time job and put them in that role,
which is essentially a fairly sophisticated role.
Just keeping up with all this shit,
which is crazy.
So let's take one guy,
give him video as a platform and then allow for him to reach millions.
And it's also the difference between someone taking on that role as a job and
someone who's extremely passionate about electronics.
Completely agree with that.
That's for you.
Like a guy like you,
you would probably,
no matter what your job is,
you would still be passionate about electronic
100% I'd still be having the exact same conversations.
Sometimes I,
I feel like I might even be more passionate because I wouldn't be jaded by the
whole thing.
You know what I mean?
Like,
I think in a weird way that might happen,
but,
uh,
you know,
there's,
there's definitely,
there's definitely this change happening right now where social media is
allowing for individuals who you don't know in your personal life to take on the
role,
uh,
where that used to be for somebody connected to you,
you know,
immediately connected to you.
Now the,
the word of mouth marketing,
which is a scent was,
which was the most powerful,
is still the most powerful,
is transitioning from word of mouth in real life.
Real words to social media words.
Because even though you might be unreachable to people in real life,
you're not because of social media.
So I'll,
so Joe Rogan is an influencer.
I'm an influencer.
Marquez is an influencer and all of a sudden you're,
you're managing this social group of a million friends.
Essentially.
That's the way they look at it.
You're building that connection.
You have this two way communication.
You're producing hundreds of videos,
you're pumping out hundreds of tweets.
It's,
uh,
you,
you take on a different role.
Wow.
And you're super responsible in a way.
Like,
say if you choose a certain phone,
it turns out to be a piece of shit.
He's,
Oh,
for sure the massive burden on you that would destroy to be unjustly.
Like there was no way it would be worth it because it would kind of like stain
you for it
ever.
Like your people's perceptions of your judgment and you know,
and most importantly if you're,
if you grew up invested in this,
you know,
like I did like just wanting to get my hands on the next thing.
It's,
if you're actually excited,
it's super hard to fake it.
You know what I mean?
It's a fake it eat one way or the other way.
It's,
there's something about the format,
the third party format,
like brands,
they'll put up their own videos without a feature video on your product.
Nobody wants that.
Nobody wants your super polished version of the way you want the thing to be
interpreted.
Uh,
in conversations I've had,
it's like I'm,
I'm playing the like unboxing videos in general.
I'm playing the role of view.
That's why traditionally they were shot point of view,
point of view because it's your head,
you're about to go experience this.
And when I was playing around with the Google Cardboard Vr,
I was like,
Oh shit,
can you imagine this idea being expanded on of consumption through someone else?
Experience having experiences that will be unavailable to you through someone
else's perspective.
Because oftentimes I'm playing with items that people don't have the money to
buy and not,
at least not immediately.
They may be thinking about it or they may just be watching it for entertainment.
There's all kinds of different viewers,
but I can imagine being a kid really wanting something and the closest I could
get to it was that experience of getting it,
opening it Cetera and imagining that perspective of as being mine,
you know?
Well the unboxing videos are always very cool because you know you get to,
you get a real sense of the product like from,
from the purchase to your hands to discovering it.
Whereas like other times you like you,
the guy already has it out.
It's already each fully charged.
He's,
he knows how to work it.
So he's swiping back and forth and showing you all the things.
But you would never be able to talk a producer of a television show into letting
you film 20 minutes on a fucking new LG phone.
They would go,
no one's going to watch.
No.
Uh,
I,
I have heard of,
I think maybe it was virgin,
somebody put,
put some tech videos in the airplanes,
which were kind of extended in,
in length.
I don't know.
People would definitely watch them.
The world is changing.
You know,
it's totally changed.
Those producers that are in that,
in that business,
in that world,
maybe they couldn't understand it,
but the audience and the numbers,
they don't lie.
Well,
the content delivery device of television,
like Tara's going to be on at eight o'clock and can go from eight to nine and
that's when you gotta be there or Dvr it.
I have to,
I love this conversation.
I feel like it's not,
it's not us who need to be adapting to them.
It's them that need to be adapted
us.
Well,
there's no need.
As technology has started to change what online video is and now you have like
Netflix documentaries and television shows and comedy specials.
What?
What is the difference between something that's on Netflix and something that's
on television?
It's,
it seems the same thing to me and that's,
it's becoming more and more prominent and it's going to get to a point where
it's going to eclipse it because they don't have the limitations
of you have to watch it this time.
It's only on,
then you've got to sit through commercials and all this silly limitation you're
dealing with,
with a more sophisticated delivery system and in the past,
sophisticated evolutions of systems are never held back.
You can't stop them.
You can try and like,
where's blockbuster?
Yeah,
they fucked up.
There was a bunch of dudes sitting around a table like this with gray hair
saying people like to go and rent a movie.
You know it's an outing.
That's what they like to do.
Do it,
and then the wife gets to pick.
That's right.
Each day that husband gets to pick on ones during tonight's mine.
I like the classics,
the classics.
For seven day rentals and late fees.
Do you remember late fees?
Can you believe that we put up with that shit?
I'll do you one better.
How about rewind fees?
Whoa.
Now I can't go with you there.
I can't get that far back.
Remember the rewind fees?
That was bullshit.
That was so you don't rewind and they're charging you and charge you money.
If you didn't roll on the ditch,
rewind the video.
You're like,
ah,
I think I did.
And then they look at it.
No you didn't.
It's like who's considering user experience?
They're like,
how about some customer service?
Well,
you know,
my friend figured out that most of the time the people that work at blockbuster
or way too dumb to know whether it's fully watched or fully rewound,
they would like look at it.
So what he would do is just fast forward it to the very end and then say it's,
look,
it's totally rewound.
They would go,
oh,
okay.
Because they didn't know if it was real loud,
couldn't where does it go like that?
Or is it like this?
Like where's,
which is the start?
Does it go clockwise?
Is it go okay?
Getting back to that conversation about the,
uh,
about the internet as a delivery method.
Uh,
there's this,
this thing happening now we're online content creators with really large
audiences are getting approached by traditional media.
You know,
they,
they are wanting to bring them over into that world to try and generate some
interest in traditional media to an audience that generally isn't interested in
that content.
And the prob there's,
there's problems occurring where those people aren't translating and vice versa,
or they're trying to mold them into something else.
There's a lot of really big content creators that have branched out in that way.
And there's some sort of feeling like once you've got,
once you're on TV,
you've made it,
you know,
which is still appealing to a lot of people,
but not,
not at all for me because when I see it,
like,
like I said before,
a more sophisticated delivery system I want for me,
we've won when we've convinced them that when we've convinced them to come work
with us,
not the other way around,
you know,
and uh,
and I feel like there's a lot of people,
there's a lot of people that are undermining how cool all of this is by taking
their services and saying and saying,
Oh,
I'm going to,
I'm not going to upload on my channel as much anymore because I have a show on
this channel or because I'm working with this brand or because I'm in
commercials now,
or whatever it is.
And that's a real thing that's happening.
Youtube stars.
That's fascinating.
So big youtube stars at getting lured into the dark side.
That's right.
They pulled over.
Real control that content.
But that's right.
We'll give you pasted these
coins from the bottom of the mountain.
That is a real thing because their whole business is based around control.
They have to control the assets like record deals,
think about record deals,
music companies,
all that shit got overhauled.
Why heard does,
I don't know what podcast company it is,
but one of the podcast networks got sold.
It got sold to some radio conglomerate or some shit like that.
I remember when that happened.
I was like,
wow,
that's weird.
Why would they want to buy a podcast network?
Nerdous it.
Then they get bought by a like Warner brothers or some kind of form a Warner
brothers.
Find out what the actual,
well,
who cares?
I mean I let him do whatever he wants to do.
I've had,
I've had offers to buy my channel.
Really sell that with pursed lips and that's right.
You said that very in serious tones.
That's right.
Yeah.
Well,
hey,
it's worth a lot of money.
A lot of people are checking it out.
We can just change the way you look at things.
Louis,
you just a little too critical.
Like,
why are you so mean when it comes to certain devices that could generate
millions of dollars if you just flavored your came imagined that life being that
person though really just a shell,
you know?
Well,
it's also,
it's completely contrary to what you're passionate about.
What you're passionate about is innovation.
Where you're passionate about is the consumer experience.
Like I was kind of a really interested,
or the last conversation that we had you,
you were talking about the user experience,
the UAE,
which I had never really thought of as a concept,
but it is,
it's not just a user interface,
but it's the experience.
How does it make you feel to finish beveled edges,
the Polish Smith last box that it comes in.
Yeah.
What is all that about?
And that's something that you only would sort of get if you are truly passionate
about this.
Let's look at Apple.
I mean they,
they're trying to control the experience.
Start to finish from the retail perspective.
There's a difference between walking into an apple store in a Verizon store.
Yeah.
The apple,
they've got it nailed.
They do have that nail.
They,
everything looks apple.
Lee,
you know,
you go into the apple store,
it's totally APP.
I feel like we shouldn't go off on apple talk again because people get suck.
It sucks.
It is.
The reality is that they make the best laptops.
They make the best desktops,
they make the best phones.
They just do that.
The android phones,
the best thing about the android phones is that they're open is that anybody
could make things for them.
Is that the screens are bigger,
is that,
you know,
there's a lot that you could watch flash on them.
There's a lot of really positives when it comes to android phones,
but when it comes to like who has made an android phone that can fuck with an
iPhone,
the closest is like that HTC m eight and I've had that.
It's good on camera.
You see one?
Yeah,
it's good.
Actually me and mark has to be,
did an inadvertent camera test out the window of our hotel.
We'd check in.
He's three,
four floors above me,
so I'm 12 he's 15 we both the exact same photo unknowingly.
I use a five s he uses the MH,
right,
and we both post to Instagram sec within seconds of each other.
Izea mine go live and right underneath I see his and you should check out.
I'll show you the results.
It's,
I've seen a bunch of the results from videos like Marcus's,
I'll show you the results.
It's obvious.
The iPhones have a better camera.
It's a better,
it's a slicker design.
It's,
there's a lot of great things to it,
but damn,
Android's fucker.
It's close.
Okay,
so really cool.
Check this out.
Just scroll down to the next one.
That's the iPhone five s on the top.
We took,
we essentially took the St and then scroll down.
God.
And that's the man.
Oh my God.
That's incredibly different.
Look at all the devotees.
It's not at the same time because the sun is different than the horizon.
No,
dude,
come on.
Really?
That's within seconds of one another.
That's insane.
Look at the deed.
How come yours?
Like look at you.
You'd see your son.
It doesn't show any like black.
What does that the bill flare.
The flare flare.
But look at his flair.
Yup.
And look at,
the interesting part for me is if you scroll down a little more and you look in
the shadow portion,
there's no detail in the MH shadows.
It's terrible.
It was like shit.
You go up to the mind,
look at the detail where the cars are parked and that building in the forefront.
Yeah.
That is fascinating that you guys did that accidentally and then yeah,
because it,
it just goes to show you like the,
the mindset,
you know,
like we both saw the cool shot where like I'm going to take the shot and,
and the difference in the output.
Yeah.
This sort of the context of the user experience,
like the,
the passionate,
you know,
a person who's into a electronics that can't,
you can't fake that.
You can't know.
It is,
that's why it's so hard.
There are so many users or guys like us that really,
really like the interface on stock.
Android like we talked about last time,
I have a nexus with me as well pretty much all the time.
But it's so hard to ditch the iPhone because when you want to make a photo,
when you want to communicate through photography,
there's just no other way right now and not theirs.
That's Sony one that takes very high mag and the one that has the extra,
extra big fat land.
The Nokia one,
there's no,
that's what it is.
Is there a Sony that has that as well?
The Sony's have some great cameras to Sony is a waterproof one.
Right.
That's to have a waterproof,
totally waterproof phone.
Definitely.
Why is this not waterproof?
That's a good question.
That's a stupid back back when back then,
like when the,
this really hasn't,
the body hasn't changed much since the five right?
Back then it really wasn't a thing.
People weren't making it.
It just,
it's relatively recent.
Samsung's is a IP rated for dust and water.
Uh,
so is,
I don't know if HTCs is,
but definitely Sony's is,
it's a relatively new thing that that's happening.
They can go like,
you know,
a meter underwater for 10 minutes.
Hey,
the next one might be the next one might be,
but it's not,
it's for them.
That's not a huge priority.
It,
this doesn't seem like a huge product.
Everybody gets their phone ruined by pouring a drink on it.
Like that's the number one reason phones get ruined.
I would say cracked screens.
Toilet,
I would take cracked screens are probably higher than water,
but they're both high speeding of cracked screens.
Cracked screens.
Almost universal,
right.
It doesn't everybody get a cracked screen of,
I've never had one,
but I've had to move a Turd to get my phone out of,
out of the toilet.
Did you kill the phone or the phone?
Survive phones or vive.
How,
how long was it English?
It literally like I got up and then it fell in the toilet and I was like,
God put my hand through her and grabbed it,
pulled it out and then,
and then uh,
write it off,
put it in a bag of rice now he didn't even wash his hands as fuck.
No.
Now I did the shaky thing and it's good enough though.
Hairdryer.
Oh really?
What you should do if that happens is 24 hours in a bag of rice.
Yeah.
It'll,
it'll pull away where the moisture would.
I usually ended up just doing it,
then having something stopped working and then take it to the APP or call the
apple store and they will send you one with that.
Apple's great with that.
Here's the weird things though.
They put,
or at least they used to,
I don't know anymore.
I used to do like some repairs on these things,
crack them open and get crazy like that,
but they used to put little litmus paper in there that would show if it got wet
every turn red.
He used to be in the headphone Jack.
I don't know.
They probably are still doing it.
He's still do it,
but if you call they don't,
there's no way from the check.
Here's a question.
When you say if you drop something in the toilet,
you drop the phone in the truck,
should you shut it off and throw it in the bag of rice?
Oh,
should you leave at all times?
It turns itself off.
But yeah,
if you,
if it's still on to turn it,
turn it off,
shut it off,
throw it in the bag of rice.
Yeah.
What I usually do is just suck the water out of it.
But,
but,
but I wasn't going to do it with the poop ones,
right?
Yeah.
Why not?
It's gross because when you suck it up,
if you look at your iPhone,
like there's the top part where the,
the,
where your ear usually goes,
but there's water that's in there.
So you stuck that and you're like pretty much sucking earwax.
It's gross.
I never,
I never thought of on my phone ever jump into that.
You mean like I go like really hard many times.
Have you done this?
Probably like five times.
So where's your phone?
Where's your ear going that you're getting ear wax on them?
If you look,
if you look,
there's like a little grill that's right there and if you look really close,
you could actually see their shit in there.
I was thinking about the Jack itself.
I know you have to suck all of them.
There's the bottom one that you suck and you suck that power.
Does that work?
Can you really suck the water out?
Well,
it really helps.
It's what I've always done.
You mean getting,
getting water away from it is going to be a positive thing,
but the guy on the phone,
customer service here,
Dude,
listen,
I've been sucking on my phones.
That cool.
I'm just taking it in the most polite way possible.
I wouldn't recommend it.
No.
Here's the answer to our other question.
1.7% of American adults identify as gay or lesbian.
1.7 C I had heard 10% that's the gays.
They just want you to
think that everyone's gay,
right?
Yeah.
God.
Damn.
Tough stat to get though.
Who's taking that?
It's a good question.
It's a really good question because what percentage of gays are in the closet
versus out?
That's a good question.
I would wonder,
what do you think again,
impossible stat to get.
I would say 50 50 yeah.
Just take 20 friends that you know and then think,
all right,
how many of those 20 people are gay?
How many people are those?
Do you think are in the closet?
How many?
Just like how it tastes.
We all know a few people that are in the closet.
Yeah.
Everybody goes,
yeah,
in public figures to speculate on.
It's really sad.
It's sad when someone was in the closet.
Do you know when you got a guy who's a friend like Justin Martin Dale who's out
and happy and silly about it,
you know,
and nobody judges them.
It's like it's no different than judging someone who,
you know,
likes to drive a certain kind of car.
So I'm like,
why did he give a fuck?
It's just,
it's a weird,
does it?
Is it more the individual though?
Like is it possible that somebody experienced is exactly the way they want it
without coming out like his kid?
Could it be that there's too much pressure to come out to,
sure they could definitely.
There's a lot of factors.
I think it's all depends entirely on your environment,
your family,
religious background,
where you grew up.
If you grew up in San Francisco,
it's probably pretty easy to be gay.
If you grew up in Kentucky,
it's probably pretty hard to come out.
You know,
you're in a fucking deer stand with a bunch of buddies and go,
hey man,
some shit.
I'm mean to get off my chest,
you know,
all listening to Garth Brooks songs and shit and like one of you just happens to
be gay.
Like that guy's fucked man.
Yeah.
He leaves the community at that point.
That's weird.
You know,
if we had a situation where one of our comedian friends came out as gay out of
nowhere,
like say if already just decided to tell us,
you know what got
pretty sure I'd be like,
Whoa,
that's weird.
Okay,
wait,
you had that one guy on this guy you 10% gay.
Oh,
Brody Brody.
Yeah.
He's 84% determined.
What would Ari with a lisp sound like?
We wouldn't have a list.
It sounds like I'm coming out of the closet guys.
Darren talking normal.
It happens.
Joe.
I think.
I think,
I think once you're out you can start to enhance it.
I think it,
yeah,
I think cause you,
you hide it and you breathe it in.
You know,
you tried to hide your gayness,
but once it's out,
it's like,
oh my God,
I'm so ready.
Well,
some gay guys would totally disagree with that because it's gay guys that like
really gay men,
like really lispy feminine gay men and gay men that like men that are men who
like other men and they don't talk.
Gail.
Yeah,
that's tough.
Girl was gay.
You know the girl was living with a guy who looked across,
you're like him Christ.
Sure.
Him and Christ.
Yeah,
I have those bears.
They wouldn't be,
you know,
it wouldn't be obvious.
No.
Right.
That's a delicious
couple.
Imagine they're great with another,
they have sex or not to just so awesome.
So what percentage do you think then are complete like flaming the whole way
versus,
I think that's never,
you'd never know.
That's PR.
I Dunno.
1.7% if it's 1.7 so let's round it off.
Let's say it's 2% that are in the closet,
2% out of the closet.
4% of all Americans gay.
We willing to say that.
I'm willing to say that.
I want to say that.
I'll go.
Yeah,
that's probably about right.
So 4% of all Americans being gay.
I'd say Super Gay dudes.
It's like 1%
and that's mostly drug pointed.
The drug probably like just raging,
like I wanna fuck you in the ass.
No Man.
I have some friends that are a,
a gay couple that live in my neighborhood and they're pretty obviously gay,
but they're not like partiers or animals or anything wacky then.
No,
not doing,
I don't think they're doing drugs.
You know what's weird about it to me is like,
I know for myself,
I don't really want to be defined by anything.
I don't want to be defined by one thing about mice and you're queer.
Queer is perfect.
I'm going to fit.
So I'm going to fit right in the LBG and somebody can,
like the last thing I want is some kind of label,
but in that world it seems like that's exactly what,
you know what I mean?
You want to be labeled.
Yeah.
It's so,
it's so weird.
It's like,
I don't know.
I think because there's a lot,
a lot
of,
um,
they want to be identified,
first of all,
they're proud to be out,
like to be out is probably like a huge relief off of your back.
Right.
It's just,
you know,
just to be out and accept and not have to hide that shit anymore.
None of to have that hovering over your head.
I'd probably probably really fucks with people.
Um,
so it's probably like an affirmation and a lot of ways to just to say you're
gay,
but the queer thing is,
I think they don't want to be,
I don't want to butcher this.
My Queer friends,
they don't want to be described as a he or a she or a gay or a straight,
they want to be that.
There's those folks too.
I mean,
otherwise,
why would it be queer?
Why wouldn't it be bisexual?
Like what are you,
are you I'm queer.
Okay.
What does that mean?
Are you gay,
straight or bisexual?
Hmm.
I'm queer.
Just queer.
So you're just all right.
I got it.
I think I got it.
I don't know if I have it.
You know,
it's so that's a real,
that's a thing that's queer,
that's queer is,
no one's ever told me that before.
You know,
just fucking Canadians.
We keep shit from you.
Yeah,
I guess so.
There's a lot of things we can,
I'm sure if I investigated I could figure it out.
But baby we had,
there's one hell of a pride parade in Toronto.
One hell of a pride because it queer pride though.
That's a fucking confusing parade because if you're truly queer he wouldn't even
show up for it cause you don't even identify with it,
you know,
identify with that group that's running that parade.
Wow.
Yeah.
I think people for the longest time have been suppressed and still are.
But I think for the longest time they didn't have an outlet where they can
identify with other people that have also been suppressed in very similar ways.
So whether it's being
gay or whether it's being transgender or whether it's being,
they didn't have a community before to support them.
They just had scattered groups of people all across the country with no way to
communicate with each other.
Yeah.
Now that you can,
it's probably the time that we're in it.
I don't think it will be like that forever.
At some point you mean?
Well,
at some point I feel like the,
it won't be as exciting as it is now to be a queer.
Here's what I mean by that is since it's only recently become as accepted as it
is now,
right?
Right.
50 years ago,
I don't know what they were going to do to somebody who came out or a hundred
years ago or whatever.
It was obviously a tougher time,
so eventually it will be so commonplace that it won't even drum up nearly the
discussion than it does now.
Yeah,
but as long as it's only 4% of the population,
that's always going to be a marginalized group.
I mean,
I guess so I can't go with you on that,
but do you think it's always going to be 4% is that something that's,
is it something that is a growing figure shrinking figure?
That's where it becomes a real problem.
And the Christian community,
because that means a bunch of queers or indoctrinate and all the young,
that's what's going on.
They're spreading their queer.
Well,
while there's a lot of people that believe that if you sexually indoctrinate
someone to world of homosexuality,
very young in life,
that they'll identify with that impresses.
It does a deep conversation,
dude to deep conversation,
but it has more to do.
What is it with the pedophile,
pedophile stuff?
I'm not saying pedophilia.
No,
no,
but,
right.
But the likelihood of a person who was molested by a pedophile turning into a
pedophile themselves.
Yeah,
I think that's documented.
That is documented.
I don't,
I don't know if those are totally related,
you know?
No,
just how young being young exp experiences you have when you're young helped
shape your perception of so many things.
It does.
And also,
um,
women who have been molested a young age tend to lean more towards prostitution
and towards a pornography and towards a lot of things along those lines that
their ideas about sexuality get morphed.
But yeah,
it's,
it's interesting,
Matt.
Um,
the,
the 4% thing,
like you know what,
that's,
there's another question like what makes someone gay?
I mean how many people are gay because of a choice.
How many people would be like fucking dealing with chicks?
I'm just going to learn,
start liking dude.
How many of them,
and I feel like the company line is that people are born gay.
But I always had difficulty with that.
I mean I have,
I have difficulty believing people are born anything.
Oh you need to meet this kid that lives on my street.
Like no,
but,
but by this I mean by this I mean that's some percentage,
some percentage of our existences nature in some percentage of our existence is
nurture.
Right?
It's a mixture.
It's not any one,
it's not concrete.
You don't come out with a concrete perspective on anything except this kid on my
street,
he's five and he's gay as fuck,
but five by five.
I think we underestimate how quickly characters built on an individual between
the ages of one to two or two to three.
We look at a five year old and for us as adults,
years is nothing.
It's a blank,
but for them it's so,
yes.
It's such a huge span in so much is happening in that period of time.
Oh yeah,
and your childhood being traumatic is incredibly hard to get over.
It's just the fact that it happened 15 years ago.
It's set the boundaries and the framework,
sort of the building blocks of your personality and to kind of go back and
repair that shit.
Very difficult to do two people know or do some people,
most people I think never do,
but as opposed to someone who's born and raised in a really,
like I have friends that grew up fucked up and they're just,
there's something about the fucked up at that they encountered that just they're
gone.
They're never going to come all the way back.
They never got to look at themselves objectively than ever going to step back
and try to fix many or any of the personality issues they might have developed
because of like a protective mechanism.
They sort of developed as a young person.
There's not going to do it.
I shut off button.
Yeah,
there's just a,
whatever it is,
they're,
they're done,
they're done growing,
changing and then other people like you meet them in their consistently
exploring their personality and their life and improving upon themselves and
doing new things.
You know,
I love when I talked to someone like,
dude,
I took up scuba dive in like bots.
That's awesome.
Tell me about scuba diving.
You know like people,
I mean that's not the best example but about someone who's like consistently and
constantly trying to expand,
you know,
their,
their experiences and try to and analyzing their life.
Then there's other people that are just in a sea of bad decision making and
alcoholism and drug abuse and gambling and this and that.
It seems like,
it seems like it,
it can,
he can come out in so many different ways,
but it ultimately stems from being happy or not being happy,
you know,
finding a way to get there.
Right?
It can mean shit can happen to you,
and you have that moment of interpretation where you can take it one way or take
it down down a different path,
and the more severe the experience,
the harder it is to take it in a positive way as we were.
That is,
I don't know.
You know what I mean?
Like for example,
failure,
like that's the main way you learn how to do something.
So I'm going to learn how to ride a bike.
Well,
if I fall off that bike,
I'm going to learn really quickly to stay focused so that that doesn't happen
because there's pain on the other end of it.
So here's this really negative thing that actually acts as the mechanism for
getting me from a to B and getting better at something.
But the pain portion on its own when you can't justify it,
when you can't figure out the end message,
when you can't figure out what I've learned because of this,
that's when it's the toughest to digest.
Yeah.
I think there's a lot of folks that tried to stay as comfortable as possible,
as much as possible,
too.
So terrified of that pain,
right.
So instead they just don't experience much like a very narrow world of,
you know,
and then maybe they'll experience like a little bit of emotional pain online
every now and again.
You know what I mean?
Like they'll put up a youtube video then read the comments
and that's,
that's the enough,
no,
no bike riding for them because that would be some real life pain.
See,
I have,
I have two little kids.
I have a four year old and a two year old.
And just like my life has changed a lot since having them just didn't analyzing
their behavior and,
and then analyzing my own in contrast to,
there's like again,
yeah.
Uh,
adults are constantly trying to find ways to avoid pain,
to avoid off,
not feeling great all the time.
Like we're complete,
you know,
risk avoidance.
I mean,
the average person,
whatever,
nine to five type individual them,
they put themselves out there for no reason.
My four year old,
there's a swing set.
He could go on the swing or he could pick one of the posts going to to the top
and climb all the way to the top and sit.
He's four.
You know,
like what is driving him to do that?
Because the adult mind would say,
oh,
you're going to break your wrist or leg or whatever,
and he might,
and someone's going to blame me for it.
Fine.
But that it's the drive portion in and of itself.
This just wanting to experiment,
that's the most exciting.
That's the part that I want to tap into.
That's the part that's contagious.
You see him do that and it's like,
shit,
why do I,
why should I fall in line?
Even if it's not directly related?
Why does the next thing I do need to be the status quo?
Like what we did today,
what we did today is not your average tech video,
right?
Well,
to tell people.
Yeah.
I was wondering if you were going to talk about it for sure.
We've talked about anything and everything.
What we did today,
we ran a little test.
I'll experiment.
Uh,
do people know?
Most people know behind this studio is an a little mini archery range.
If you don't know that,
you shouldn't know that.
There's a couple of pictures on Joe's Instagram feed.
That's how I knew about it.
Uh,
a little mini archery range and the experiment involved bringing some technology
components out here to figure out how they would resist the impact of an Arrow,
right?
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
Have I done a good job so far?
I feel like I'm dancing around the subject.
Okay.
The upcoming iPhone,
the iPhone six supposedly has a sapphire display or a display that's partially
made of Sapphire.
Here's a problem with Sapphire.
How Tech,
how technical do you want to get up?
Get in there.
Okay.
Sapphires are really hard material.
They'd been using it on watch faces for a long time.
It doesn't scratch easily.
If you buy a Rolex or something,
it's probably got a sapphire face or something like that,
something like that.
But it's really expensive and it's really brittle.
So for a flexible surface it would be shit,
shit shitty.
And what a lot of people don't realize is that even if you have a,
a stiff phone,
like an iPhone,
there's a certain amount of flex that it can put up with without chipping or
shattering like something like this.
You know,
you can put some force on it,
you could sit on it,
et cetera.
It doesn't crack when you bend over type stuff or chip very easily,
although people crack them anyway,
smash him.
Anyways,
so co companies came out with things like gorilla glass,
which are these flexible kinds of glass that are made out of a laminated Paulie
type bullshit.
A little bit of everything in there,
some glass,
some minerals,
some plastic.
These new Sapphire one,
which is supposed to be patented by apple is supposed to be the strongest we've
ever seen.
So fewer people are going to end up in the apple store with a cracked iPhone.
Essentially.
That's,
that's the way it's looking right now.
So my Buddy Marquez,
who we talked about earlier,
God is hands on and through a very similar source to who I've gotten my hands on
components from before.
Got His hands on this glass.
Supposedly,
allegedly,
whatever.
No,
no,
no.
A definitiveness there.
But what we think is the,
the upcoming glass,
put it through its paces,
it scratched it with a knife,
scratched it with keys,
would not scratch,
right.
Very durable.
But I met,
I was unimpressed because I said,
well,
we need to bust the thing.
We can need to take the thing to the point of destruction.
This is not enough.
And I wasn't the only one.
There were people in the comments that were like,
well dude,
you,
he did a great video.
So he,
he doesn't deserve it.
But they were like,
well dude,
sure you bent it and scratched it,
but at what point is it,
is it going to be destroyed?
And so,
uh,
we wanted to test that.
So I sent him a message where I said,
listen,
me,
you,
let's figure out how to get this done.
I think,
uh,
maybe we should go to a gun range.
That's what I said to him at first.
I said,
yeah.
He said,
on Dm,
I said,
have you ever been to a gun range?
He said,
I like where this is going.
Then I responded with,
I think I can do one better.
I said,
well,
you think about an arrow.
He said,
sold,
right?
I said,
let me reach out to maybe reach out to Joe.
So then I sent a message to Joe.
Uh,
it was kind of vague.
I liked the way it was phrased though.
I said,
leaked iPhone Sapphire screen in Arrow in a high speed camera.
That was it.
Dot,
dot.
Dot.
What are you think about that?
And he responded with,
Fuck Yeah,
you hear me folks?
No hesitation.
Fuck Ya.
Right in the DM.
And that's what I love about this guy right here.
So we came down and we did it.
We made it happen in the video is going to go live.
I have a shit ton of data to look through because this camera's shooting at nine
60 fps,
which we,
I'm going to have the calculation wrong here,
but essentially an eight second clip is an enormous amount of footage.
It's like minutes worth so over over a minute.
960 frames per second.
That's what we shot it at the impact and 60.
Yeah,
it turned out it was,
it was like one minute of video equals one second.
Was that the,
is that,
is that it?
I don't know.
I don't want to go on record as,
as cause I'm going to be wrong if I do go on record,
but for those that are really into this shit,
we were shooting on a an fs 700 at the highest frame rate possible and uh,
and basically we're going to try and give you guys the most accurate
representation of the impact that we can.
And uh,
I mean I'm not going to spill it here.
We got to leave a little reason to go check out the video,
but uh,
interesting results.
Yes,
we're not going to spill it,
but guess who wins?
We did some other stuff too.
Not The phone.
We didn't stop at the,
at the Sapphire,
the upcoming Sapphire.
We have what?
We had more fun than that.
So plenty of incentive to head over to unbox therapy.
Hit the subscribe button right now.
So you're ready when the video goes live because we're about to take over the
Internet and we're counting on you guys to help us get there.
Oh,
we'll definitely promote it.
We shot some shit.
We shot at quite a bunch of shit.
Yeah,
definitely.
It was,
uh,
it was worth doing.
Definitely for sure.
Yeah.
So yeah,
we brought in a lot of cool people down.
I should shout everybody out.
We brought,
uh,
Austin Evans.
We brought John from TLD we brought,
mark has of course.
Who else am I missing right now?
I don't think anybody,
no,
I probably am been being an answer right now.
Uh,
Josh also from TLD was there
anyway.
Anyway,
we made it happens and a bunch of quick cool people.
Way Too many cameras were in the back there.
You're going to see it all.
We got behind the scenes.
We got in front of the scenes.
This is destruction at its best.
It was awesome.
It went down.
Go watch a video.
What,
what is it about men that uh,
we were talking about this,
right?
Like men wanting to shoot things and blow them up.
Like if you had to compare like the numbers,
just the sheer numbers.
Forget about how many people are gay.
The sheer number of things of things that go blown out by men.
You know,
like what does my holes,
yeah.
No checks to stick and firecrackers up there.
But I think things that get like,
like blown up in a field,
how many things get blown up in the field that are growing up?
I used to fish,
he used to put firecrackers in their mouth and just blow them up after fishing.
That's so rude.
You should be,
you should be on some watch list somewhere.
You know that you weren't before.
You are now.
Yeah.
Um,
then like,
like how many different like refrigerators have been like stuffed full of
dynamite.
It's all men.
Right.
When I was a kid I had an obsession with like opening stuff like this up.
They would by my parents would buy me some awesome piece of technology and I
would want to get inside of it like keyboards and Walkmans.
I used to open those up wow.
To just see what they were made of.
I don't know if this is an extension of that,
but ultimately you get to see what the thing is made of.
You know what I mean?
That's part of it I think for sure to see inside.
Once you shoot it,
look inside,
but blowing things up.
It's also just to just blow things up.
You're right,
you're right.
I'm stretching on that.
I was trying to put a student on the two different desires,
like your desire is like the desire to see the wiring under the board,
which all real when the also,
when the Arrow hits it,
like we're so used to seeing this in the context of Ooh,
don't drop it.
Don't spill on it to see it in that light where fuck you.
You know this thing,
right,
that you've been so concerned about for so long,
you know,
yet gentle with it.
You Bait,
we fucking baby
these things.
True.
You know?
And so to take the,
to take this thing that's on your conscience all the time.
Where is it?
Do I have it is in my pocket,
right?
Who doesn't do the slap?
The slap,
slap.
Did Wallet Phone.
You don't leave that premises until it's in there.
So to say,
fuck it.
Even for a minute,
even for a second,
that's a win.
Or you're just destroying getting off on the fact you destroy things.
But if it was,
I mean it was cool,
but like,
let's say we put some,
I don't know,
a fucking banana there wouldn't have been quite the same.
Yeah,
no,
definitely more valuable things are cool to see.
Explode for whatever.
Yeah,
I guess.
Yeah.
Um,
what was I gonna say?
Oh,
exploding things.
I don't know.
Whenever I lost it,
I lost whatever it was.
It's exciting.
I mean,
there's also this,
just from a very straight up primal perspective,
this idea of the impending doom.
As a viewer,
you get to wait,
you get to watch,
but you know the outcome.
You already know what the fuck's going to happen,
but you need to see it happen anyways.
I know what I was going to say.
BLENDTEC blenders.
You ever seen that with a plan?
With a band?
It's crazy.
They blend the fucking iPhone.
They blend a shout.
I've got dude blends.
My Vitamix couldn't take.
I have a Vitamix and I blend tech and it couldn't do a pineapple.
I cut up,
pop it up,
pineapple in there.
It just overheat.
Kept on overheating.
But luckily there's a sensor in there that you just have to unplug it and wait
30 minutes and shit.
But I'm like,
wait a second,
why can't this shit do a pineapple?
But like he got to man up and get the tech man.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
I enjoyed the Vitamix.
You know what I like about the Vitamix,
that plunger thing?
Yeah.
The plunger think is nice,
but I never used it for anything other than Kale shakes.
Right.
But uh,
it's perfect for Kale.
Shakes works great,
but the blend techs better even for Kale shakes cause it really liquefies it,
it brings it down to like a much smaller,
smaller size particle does it?
I used my Blendtec though every day or my Vitamix everyday.
Like even if I'm just getting like,
Hey,
I'm gonna get some apple juice,
I'll put some apple juice and ice in it and make it like a frozen I,
it's good man.
It's good.
I mean you,
you should look if the more you could give your digestive system a break,
blend shit up like that.
Like vegetables.
It's good for you.
It's good.
It helps you poop too.
Could Lord,
that's the best thing about those Kale shakes.
The poops are fantastic.
I need help there,
man.
I guess I got to jump on a killed train.
Still Wild Log ride.
Like,
like you're working on the Yukon and there's a river and then the,
the logs broke loose and they went down current leg.
Ah,
that's is like when you take a shit,
it's just like,
Whoa,
hang on.
Just hang on.
Perfect.
Whew.
And then you'd be thinking like,
why hasn't my shit always like this?
Sometimes you know,
you're going to think I gotta take a shit.
I definitely have to take a shit.
All right,
let me just sit here and wait for this to come out.
How long should it shit?
How long should you be in there for?
How long should it be sitting down for?
It's really truly dependent on your diet,
right?
I think
the easier it is for you to shit for you,
for Joe Rogan and experiencing in the bathroom.
What's the perfect length of time?
It depends on if I have my phone with me cause sometimes I'll drag it out.
Even when I'm done,
we're good magazine or a book that I'm into,
I'll drag it out like I'm done shitting finished.
What is,
don't feel like pulling my pants up.
What kind of have you said or what's your record for time after you've been
finished for still chilling with the phone.
My legs go numb all the time.
Tell you that
especially when you got the iPhone are aren't used to have a joke about it.
So true.
You know,
you get that iPhone resting on your elbows and your thighs and you're leaning
forward and you're just cutting off all that out your legs essentially.
Yeah.
Have you ever masturbated on the toilet?
It's sitting on,
that's not shading,
but just sitting on the toilet now
like I had when the girl was over and I couldn't masturbate in front of her.
So I would go to the bathroom.
Like I might take a shower and then you just try to masturbate while sitting on
the toilet.
Why don't you just have sex with her?
She's right there.
Weren't into it.
Too much work.
So what happened?
What?
What was it?
What was the oak?
It's really hard.
Like I've only done it once.
I've tried like three times.
Know it's something about the sitting on the toilet.
It's not.
It takes you out of position.
I remember somebody sending me something,
not a product.
They want it to send me a product because they say we don't sit on the toilet
properly and it's distinct to adjust the way you sit.
Oh thing.
That's what it was.
Platforms squat what it was.
Imagine that.
Review.
My God.
Yeah.
That's supposedly the the way you're supposed to have shit.
I did.
I looked it up.
I went to their website and I was like,
Holy Shit.
Everyone's shitting the wrong way.
Yeah,
we are.
That is true.
It is easier for your bowels to work if you're,
if it like you can also sort of adjust your posture when you're over.
It's overtop.
Yeah,
cause I think it's probably the way I'm doing it with my phone while I'm leaning
forward and I'm saying this is probably the worst worst.
Like yeah,
we should do probably go straighten up and like mimic the squatting.
The perfect technique with Joe Rogan.
Yeah.
This is how you shit.
Your mom never taught you this?
I'm here for you.
Yeah.
I think like a squatting sort of a thing like that like with a,
with a straight back and it'd be the way to do it.
We got to fix the morning pee Boehner problem because that shit like I still
like I'm not good at it.
What's that?
What do you mean?
Like where you have to like do that weird position to stand over the toilet and
puts your boner down just to pee and oh well you just got to just go outside.
Is that what you do see outside?
Really?
That's what you do.
Get close to get one one with you have a piss pot.
Have we talked about this?
I I have a pissed pie.
No,
it's outside.
I like to pee outside for some reason.
It's just more comforting and he's like,
I'll just walk outside and pee and animal in the pot.
The pot out there.
It's a pot that's like a planted pot books,
little fertilizer for the plants.
It's not good for it.
No,
not at all.
Dog piss kills lawns.
I know that.
Definitely yellow based
disaster.
Yeah,
like the,
it stops being green and I don't know what's in a dog's pice.
It's that Monya but it doesn't seem to be the same as a human.
Like when you pee on the grass,
like if you pee on your grass,
it doesn't seem to kill the grass.
Dog Tastes the same
now.
But you could smell dog pee.
It smells like regular P.
Kathy's disgust.
I don't know what you're into man.
But dirty little animals.
My cat,
my oldest cat,
oh,
she's problems.
She shits in front of the toilet now.
She's old as fuck.
She's 18 right in front of my toilet and it's like great shit or something.
They'd mess.
They're getting old when they get old man,
cat fall apart.
I mean the,
the hang in there for a long time.
Like my cats,
18 fucking years old.
She's hanging in there,
but every night,
well she doesn't know what's going on.
She's 18,
she's probably got some sort of a neurological issue.
Some Alzheimer's can get Alzheimer's or something like that,
but she'll,
she just a racist as fuck shit up,
screaming in words that night.
I don't even know if she can,
um,
she remembers where the litter boxes or she's to litter boxes in the house,
but sometimes she's in the bathroom and she'll just shit in the wrong bathroom
on the floor.
This is all new like over the,
that and thoughts.
Also having problems jumping on little counters like,
you know,
it's just like falls all the time.
And I think she's starting to get blind or something.
They just get week two.
So at what point tomorrow?
Bullets?
No,
we got a letter.
I don't want her to suffer,
you know,
if I thought she was suffering like most of the time she's cool.
She's,
she has a problem shitting and you know,
chickpeas in the wrong spots and putting an animal down.
I put my dog down.
Well,
I mean,
I didn't put it down.
You've been there.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's horrible.
It's weird.
It's hard.
It's weird because you know,
you don't do that to people.
Well,
you know,
euthanasia,
some peace.
Some people say it's more humane.
Well,
it is more humane.
Yeah.
It's certainly more humane if you knew that someone that you love dearly was
suffering in some horrible way and they would probably stay alive for months or
maybe even a year in this state before they,
their body eventually gave out mean there's no hope to bring them back.
The problem is there's so many people that would kill their parents.
There's so many people that would kill loved ones,
kill him if they had the choice like people have had.
There's been situations where a husband or a wife had been critical and critical
condition and the wife had been arguing to pull the plug,
or the husband had been arguing to pull the plug and the massive controversy,
the family gets involved.
Everybody's angry,
you know,
so it's,
you can't just do that,
you know,
it's,
it's what about the person themselves?
Making a call,
like if they're still cognizant,
how can you tell they're cognizant.
They want to kill themselves.
I mean it's like suicides illegal,
which is hilarious.
Not Everywhere.
No,
the other countries you mean?
Yeah.
Um,
but in America,
essentially it's illegal everywhere.
Right?
You know,
euthanasia as illegal.
The Kevorkian guy who will see I person,
I don't have a problem with it.
If a person,
if a person could pass a psychological evaluation that they're cognizant,
we their basic psychological evaluation and they say,
listen,
I'm sick of suffering or whatever,
but there needs to be suicide house.
So it was like,
you know,
they can go in and just like a big hole in the ground falling or something like,
like there should be a witness there should.
Well,
how about that suicide forest in Japan?
Yeah.
That's weird.
The way people choose to do it through the choose to do it with as little pain
as possible.
Very few people jump into volcanoes.
You know?
How many of you have bad ass way to go?
Right.
How long would that take me?
Be Instant.
Yeah.
He went head first.
Instant.
I think so.
Yeah.
You pay basically they would just burst in the flying.
I mean that's what they used to do.
Right.
To bad people.
And you'd throw them in the volcanoes,
didn't they do that?
And I don't know why day,
never heard about,
I'm sure it's happening.
Come on man.
They used to sacrifice sent to that volcano gods it.
But I don't know if that's a real thing or not.
We'll sacrifice.
Certainly a real thing.
So you to assume sacrifice bubble Kanal would be like the most about cool way to
do it.
Definitely.
And Gentlemen,
how about like that Braveheart shit where they,
the torture and what making everybody watched the torture.
Like that's might be more bad ass because you,
you're intentionally keeping the guy alive.
Yeah.
But that's killing someone.
That's not like human sacrifice.
Oh,
it's like,
oh I guess you're saying is it is a form of punishment,
but they never sacrificing the cool people.
They're always sacrificing the assholes.
They don't like anyway.
But by whose standards are they an asshole that's a problem king or whoever.
He didn't give a fuck about them.
Right.
But the king,
by the time the guy gets to be a king,
who knows whether he's a good guy or not his judgment.
Oh,
he,
I guarantee you he is not Joe versus the volcano.
What does that Matt Ryan Movie.
Yeah,
but Tom Hanks and Meg Ryan,
something about sacrificing something to them.
Okay.
Now you sacrifice your fucking hour and a half of your life.
[inaudible]
connection is sacrifice.
Big Meg,
Meg Ryan,
Tom Hanks movie.
Oh Christ.
Try watching like sleepless in Seattle.
That was like one of the first Internet based love affair movies.
Oh God,
we may,
isn't that you've got mail sleepless in Seattle.
They were having an online correspondence.
Right?
I think that was,
you've got got mail,
is it?
Yeah.
What was sleepless in Seattle was one where she had,
she squirted in the Deli or something.
I remember she had to orgasm in the restaurant.
Oh,
it's famous for that.
It wasn't that also like,
oh,
that was like they sent each other actual letters.
Is that what it was?
It was Billy crystal.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
So you've gotten mail was the first,
what year was you've got mail?
I would say 95 six okay.
Let's say that out in Seattle 95 but you see you've got mail that was an AOL
thing that it said.
Do you got mail?
Sleepless in Seattle was 1993 yeah.
Okay.
This is a radio talk show that they called in.
That's what it was.
You've got mail in 1998 interesting.
So 93 sleepless in Seattle was radio.
So that was before.
Yeah,
that was [inaudible] 98 was essentially you've got mail was like right when,
four years into the Internet invasion in our culture.
That was probably all a number 5.0 really confusing.
Yeah.
Time.
I've still know people like old people who they,
their perception of who AOL is and what they do is all confused.
Like cause people will,
you know what I mean?
Like I don't want to call anybody out,
but you know like AOL was a service provider.
They had a browser right at one time.
Like you would get a disc that comes along with your service.
You sign up and you get a CD that you have to put in and install their software.
Do you remember that?
Yeah.
Yeah,
so so then the,
and then they essentially became a media company,
which is what they are now.
They have,
they own some tech sites.
It's the reason I'm familiar and they have of course their own website,
but does anybody still use AOL as a that's what I was wondering.
Yeah.
I think a lot of people still actually use a gold weight.
He sent me a fucking AOL email address.
There you go.
I was like,
no way.
There's still out there.
He's like,
I'm old school.
Dave is awesome.
The member direct directory search got me leg.
You used to be able to just type in your address and it would find anybody who
had AOL around you based on your your miles and I found out like girls that
lived down the street from me and then I just started hooking up with them.
They can probably fucking sued them.
So Burst Stalker Internet privacy back then does not.
No one knew what the fuck.
You can just send them a message and I used to like,
you know,
anyone could get a message to anyway,
so like if your mom was on AOL and she had an account,
like somebody,
a stranger could just be like,
Hey lady,
you want to fuck.
I know.
Isn't it funny that like given the option like message boards and AOL given the
option to use your actual name.
Like I have a message board and my message board has shit,
we'll look at it right now.
I want to say like at least 10 million posts.
How many millions.
Okay.
7 million posts in the main forum will a half a million posts in the podcast
forum.
That combat sports forum is 697,000 the cont farm is 1,700,000 that's the Oh g
message board right there.
So it's been around a long fucking time.
There's a lot of posts on it,
but like
the actual number of people that use a real name,
it's almost none.
Oh,
on a message board.
Definitely,
yeah.
Given the opportunity.
Yeah.
I mean,
I use my real name,
but if I'll go through the,
the podcast forum or the,
any of the form,
it's all crazy names.
Shizam Biz,
a Wally writer.
DERPA.
I mean,
everyone's got these whacking King Phoenix.
He's not your name on the fucker.
People used to get with email too.
So how many,
how many do you think I got the number here?
Uh,
still use AOL per year as a service,
as a service that they pay for a service.
I will say,
I'm going to say 4 million.
Okay.
What would you think this is obviously us numbers only.
Yeah.
Okay.
How many people are currently subscribers to the Internet?
Through AOL?
You said 4 million.
Four.
And to think there's probably nothing really just subscribed to any more.
It's just a,
well still charging them.
I gotta think I gotta feel like it's less than that.
I don't know.
I got to feel like I'm underestimating.
I feel like if I had 10 okay,
go do you want 10?
I'll say,
I'll take 10 take 10 it's 2.5 million.
That's pretty close.
I got greedy.
It's amazing that it's 2 million.
So it's still a lot of people.
What was it in its Hay Day?
It's a good question.
I don't,
I remember,
wait a minute,
what was that merger?
It was time and AOL time.
Media and AOL,
right?
Yeah.
It was like the epitome of the DOTCOM fallout.
Like that acquisition where they value,
they valued AOL at some enormous figure.
I think I'm right about that.
I'm talking about a lot of things today.
Worms.
Welcome to the puck.
Well now it's just,
that's a hill.
Well yeah,
you could just do all the new site similar to Yahoo.
Wow.
It looks so weird.
Weird.
It's looks so odd.
Yup.
And see there's an exact,
remember how we were talking about traditional media before.
There is an example of a company essentially losing its foothold in an
incredibly short span of time where they were the way to get on the internet and
then a decade later there are news site.
Yeah,
Whoa,
wait a minute.
And they started buying up,
you know,
media properties,
websites that are successful,
et cetera.
Trying to get back into the game in some way.
But that's a,
that's another,
that's an example of how,
how the acceleration is happening now,
where adaptation is more necessary than ever.
You can never rest on what you're currently doing.
You always have to be moving onto the next thing because,
or your
or you turn into a well.
Yeah.
And there's also going to be times where whatever you use to do just doesn't
exist anymore.
It's going to go away.
Like if,
if blockbuster tried to stay open in some way,
shape or form,
it wouldn't have made it.
Nobody needs that anymore.
So it went away.
No.
You know,
there's going to be a lot of those kinds of things when things turn digital,
like record stores are,
they still exist,
but it's because records have become kind of cool.
Yeah,
like an actual record.
It'll always be there in some format,
but it just won't be the status quo.
Like comic book stores,
like Comic Book Stores are cool because to have a physical copy of Spiderman one
is pretty dope.
But you know what,
you can get that marvel has an app that you can get on your iPad.
Right.
And you watch comic books on an Ipod on better comics met marvel.
I think it's more,
marvel has one.
There's also another really big one I think is called comics Ologie or something
like that.
They had recently purchased by Amazon.
Anyway,
I'm sorry.
It's the best way to look at comic books because you flip frame by frame so you
don't have spoilers.
Like you know,
sometimes you'd be reading a comic book,
you see the next page.
Yeah.
You see the explosion that's in the next page and you go,
Oh damn,
that's going to happen.
It's actually better.
What's the bids is better because you're literally going frame by frame.
Every frame is in a unique and rain and you put it down and pick it back up.
You're right where you left off dude reading comic books and also it's not like
a limited edition.
You can't get it.
They could reproduce every God damn Concorde that ever existed in a digital form
and they'd be fools not to and they could do like Netflix,
like subscription packages where you could just read all you can.
Yeah.
Not Actually had to buy them as one.
If you're willing to pay a monthly fee or something like that to make it
accessible to the average fan and the real big wig sort of comic book collectors
that are willing to pay.
How much is Spiderman one co worth?
Oh,
I have no idea.
Probably that's an interesting answer.
Money,
right?
Spiderman,
one insane amounts of million bucks.
I don't know.
Something crazy like that.
Most people are not going to have it,
but you could easily get it if you're a regular kid who had an iPad.
Like they could just upload it digitally and it'd be great.
Yeah,
no problem.
And it would make thing.
There's this fear though.
There's this fear though that it brings down,
it has the potential to bring down the overall economic value of the more of
that independent marketplace where if people aren't going out and spending $8
per,
you know,
uh,
comic than overall,
there might be less money.
They're less incentive to get into it and less like this is,
this is the music businesses argument,
right?
About independent stuff.
So don't think that that makes any sense though,
because I think that you're just going to make people more excited.
You're dealing with 350 million people in this country alone,
right?
You're getting more access to the comic book and I think it's going to make them
more excited about it.
The physical copies still going to be worth a massive amount of money.
I don't think it undervalues it at all.
I think,
in fact,
it probably makes it more exciting to actually hold the copy of it.
Right.
But there,
but there will be fewer comic book stores than there were before.
Will there be?
I don't.
I don't know.
I don't even know how many exist.
Still love to have the physical thing in front of them.
Yeah,
I do too.
I don't know.
I think it's a mix.
If you look at like,
Eh,
well,
eh,
for example,
movies,
could you sustain a big budget?
Michael Bay?
How much money does he spend on transformers?
If people aren't going to go to the movie theater and spend $15 in another 10 on
popcorn,
is Michael Bay able to make his movies anymore?
Yeah,
he is.
Yeah.
At the same budget.
You buy them online.
Right.
But that's what I mean is the consumption medium.
Once you're online,
you're expectation is that it's not going to cost you as much as it costs you at
the theater.
It's the context of the theater that pulls that money out of your pocket.
The highest number
Spiderman one has generated is this for the grade,
the grade them front,
of course 0.5 which is a complete magazine at 1.0 which is a very poor 0.5 is
fetched as much as $1,600 for a complete shitty torn apart Spiderman.
Wow.
For the highest grade.
For a perfect copy.
1.1 million.
I was close on that estimate.
Yeah,
you're dead on.
And that's a amazing fantasy.
It's only the,
um,
that is the original Spiderman.
Amazing fantasy had Spiderman on the cover and it was the very first time that
we were introduced to Spiderman.
It's only the third comic book to break $1 million.
The other two are action comics,
number one and detective comics number 27.
Amazing.
But I mean books for some paper see,
but people,
but look at there,
it's like the shitty version of it.
It's all fucked up.
It's only when we're 1600 bucks but the best perfect,
crisp,
clean as a huge gap.
I think there's always going to be that.
Again,
I completely agree with you that that's always going to exist to,
I guess the part I'm talking about,
it's just more mass consumption that if the mass consumption medium was paper
that needed to be distributed everywhere,
the average cost of consumption for the average user would be higher than it is
in a subscription based model.
Like Netflix for example is $8 a month.
But what did you spend on rentals before Netflix exists?
Did a lot more,
lot more.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's a good way of looking at it.
And also,
um,
the amount of comics that are released,
like new ones that are digitally released,
right?
Like right now,
the amount of apps just for viewing comic books is,
you know there's a cop ball,
but it's not like the same.
I mean if you used to be able to go to any grocery store anywhere and there
would be an aisle that had comic books,
there'd be like a thing that spun around that little rack that had comic books
on it that slowly is going to be digital.
Yeah.
So it's Kinda like our Amazon conversation from earlier where streamlining the
delivery method inevitably cuts money from,
from that transaction.
It kind of does,
I guess be,
can't think that,
no,
no.
I'm not supporting that.
I'm just saying that that's the counter argument in all this stuff and probably
the better analogy is the Michael Bay one is this idea that the traditional
model as fucked up as it is,
and maybe the most original ideas aren't getting out.
It generates a fuck ton of money.
Yeah.
It's interesting,
but it's an inevitable part of innovation.
Like the horse shoe maker of the 18 hundreds it's probably so pissed when cars
came along.
Yeah.
He's definitely got this fucking house with a horse.
Shoes.
My whole,
my kingdom is from horseshoes.
I'd like to see his reaction.
He's probably so mad.
You know guys probably going ape shit right now.
You don't need a fucking car.
Okay.
He's not that expensive.
All of a sudden he became Jerry Seinfeld.
I don't know.
Well,
why do you need,
Hey,
he strikes me as a horse shoe kind of game.
Oh,
he's a car guy.
Opposite of a horse guys.
True.
Like a million
cars.
Right.
But he's got old ones.
Yeah.
The thing is Olin torches,
that's his main thing though.
Porsche's his main thing.
Porsche nine 11.
She's got like some ungodly number of portion.
Better cars overall.
Him Or Leno?
Leno.
Wow.
Leno was a gangster.
He has a full time staff that takes care of his cars there in a warehouse.
Jeez.
He has her online show.
Yeah,
he's got some giant slate airport.
Wow.
He also has a,
um,
a show,
a web show that he does like all based on cars breaking down cars.
Seinfeld has that cars and coffee.
She has watched it.
He's pretty close.
It's close.
Second.
His show is more a,
I mean it's a little bit about the car,
but more about hanging out with unique individuals.
I don't mind that show.
No,
it's not bad.
You think about a traditional media guy from 90 the nineties I think it's a
decent transition.
It's definitely better than that marriage ref thing.
Whatever that was on TV.
That was dog shit.
Yeah.
But you can't fix marriages.
Who the fuck told you to fix marriages?
This is how you fix it.
You break up,
he break them and you tell the people that get,
get your shit together and meet somebody else and don't let this happen again.
Yeah.
Don't let it get to the point where you're on TV,
working at your grievances,
sniping at each other in front of America.
But he,
his his coffee show a car,
comedians in cars or whatever.
It kind of has like a podcast vibe to it a little bit.
Very much.
So it's probably edited a little too much for my taste,
but otherwise I feel like you're sort of getting an uncensored version of both
individuals.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
And it's also a passion project,
whereas he doesn't need any money exactly how he doesn't make much from it.
Although they're still getting those accurate ads in there.
They are sure they're nice and smooth too.
And they're good ads.
Um,
he's good at it.
He's good at the show.
He really loves cars.
But that's what's why it's passion projects.
Like he's,
he really is a guy.
Like he was driving a 1973 Porsche nine 11 rs,
which is a very rare car.
It's worth $1 million.
Yeah.
And he was driving it around with someone.
Uh,
I forget who it was.
It was in the car with them,
but I think it's the guy who hosts Seth Meyers that his name.
Yeah,
that guy.
I think it was him,
one of those,
some comedian character,
whoever it was.
Sure.
And you know,
you could tell as he's describing the car,
like these are Gerry's words,
these are real car nut.
So it really,
there's such a difference between that and someone who is just doing that eight
gig.
Like there's plenty of those guys online that are doing the car gig because they
could have been a weather caster or they could have been journalism's.
Yeah.
Not even that.
I mean,
it could have been a fucking top 40 DJ or something.
Right.
But instead they're reviewing cars.
This is the automatic transition transmission,
Kris Krane speed.
Dual clutch setup.
Yeah.
It is a difference between that and like Matt Farah,
who's a friend of mine who has a show called drive,
he's on that.
And pretty much if you got a script in a teleprompter,
you're doing it wrong.
Yeah.
And that's the thing about like,
if you can pursue your interests,
you will never work a day in your life.
If you can actually find a job where you're doing what you love and lasts,
it becomes a burden,
which also you can fuck up.
You can fuck up.
And the thing that you love can become your,
you know,
it's like marrying your mistress,
you know?
Yeah.
At least you're still doing it your way and fucking up your way.
You know,
it's still,
it's so different than having somebody else tell you what's right and wrong.
Take spirits at yourself like,
like sort of like the bicycle thing.
Someone can tell you you can,
you're going to fall,
but it's,
you're never going to learn as fast as experiencing the failure and,
and,
and uh,
iterating based on it.
You know,
that's something that I think makes like youtube for example,
so great is that the content producers themselves is keeping track of so many
different war producers were created,
were conning creators,
writers,
whatever,
wearing all these different hats.
So you get to essentially see,
uh,
so many different perspectives on,
on the output.
What would eventually becomes the video and that job used to take def,
that's a super common question I get when people,
when I talk to people is you do the,
you mean you do all that on your own?
All of it.
Like what,
where's the,
what about the camera guy?
What about this game,
that guide,
et Cetera.
And,
uh,
but there is some level of control and creativity and imagination that can come
free when you know how to do everything.
You know what I mean?
When there aren't,
you aren't seeing physical barriers everywhere.
You're like,
I know how to do that.
Well,
you also seeing you in an undirected atmosphere.
Exactly.
Really you,
and you're an interesting guy.
You're a passionate guy about all these different things that you're reviewing.
So it's,
it's,
it draws you in.
There's no,
there's no fakeness to it all.
There's no way in the very produced late in the back,
all of us had ideas,
you know what I mean?
Everyone was directing everyone else and themselves and the whole thing.
And if in a more regimented environment,
it just sucks the life out of everything.
What we were talking about that if we had a producer back there that was calling
the clipboard,
meanwhile I was just five guys laughing at steris.
Right.
And just like,
and trying to make the best video too.
Like everybody's idea was clearly about trying to like,
maybe we could get this shot.
What about that?
Maybe we could do that or this.
And it became like we were ramping it up and escalating it to make it better.
And I feel like,
I feel like that's what exposes the traditional media model in the sense that
like if we're having fun,
it's going to come through.
Coming back to the social media kind of element were for these guys friends,
we need to get as close to the experience of having them,
uh,
here as we can for them to get the most out of the video.
And every,
every time you put this businessperson or whoever in between that communication
spectrum,
all of a sudden there's this filter and audiences are more sophisticated than
ever.
And that's why I feel like youtube is the place.
It's the ultimate battleground because everybody has equal access to viewership.
And so you can come with your big budget and you can come with your fancy voice,
the one you were doing there,
the fancy boy,
you can come with your million dollars.
In fact,
bringing in million dollar ring it,
bring it in new organic shit.
We'll win.
In fact,
in fact,
a couple of years ago,
maybe a couple of years ago,
Google thought we need more premium content on youtube.
So they had the launched this premium content initiative,
spent an enormous amount of money,
like $100 million to convince traditional media people to bring their content to
youtube.
Almost everything within that initiative,
a initiative bombed.
Wow.
Fuck.
It wasn't a passion based because it wasn't passion based and it wasn't organic
to the platform.
It was this really weird kind of Frankenstein version of it.
You know,
and I,
you know,
I'm,
I'm really passionate about it.
I'm really passionate about people that are web native remaining that way,
you know,
and a fat paycheck.
Not necessarily changing that.
Yeah,
I don't think it would change that for you.
You,
you,
you really do enjoy it and love it.
And the only thing that would change is if it became a burden,
you know,
if it became you are beholden to another company,
you are beholden to,
if you had Sony sponsors unblocked,
but Sony sponsored unbox therapy or,
well dude,
I mean it's not,
it's not impossible.
That call.
I mean on the web there's this advertising is the web and no one wants to talk
about that.
You know,
people want to run ad block and pretend that it doesn't exist.
Every site you love,
every video you love,
every thing important and interesting on the web or the or a lot of it,
the vast majority of it is supported by the fact that brands are paying to be in
your face.
Google exists because they're an advertising company,
first and foremost.
That's how they keep the doors open.
But there's this really weird thing where people,
you know,
hey haters,
whoever,
people want to come on there and pretend that it's actually something else
they're participating in.
But if it wasn't for advertising in real money finding its way to the web,
none of us would be here right now.
You need it to survive and you needed to invest back in the content.
I'm out here in La Right now shooting fucking arrows.
It's not free.
I get a $10,000 camera back there.
If you want to see cool shit,
it's going to cost you,
but at least in this environment,
you know it's spent on the actual thing and not spent on some woman walking
around with a clipboard.
Right.
Well,
I've been to certain youtube shows that are super overproduced.
Yeah.
Have you ever seen youtube shows where they do it like a Hollywood show where
they have makeup artists and producers and directors?
There's a,
there's a guy that's holding the camera and there's another guy directing it and
someone who's overviewing the thing.
I've seen like six,
seven people and I've been on the same sets,
man.
And what is that?
That's the blockbuster effect.
Those are the traditional people taking the easiest path to secure their
position without being imaginative.
It's also people that think that you have to do that in order to be legit,
you have to have all those roles.
That's right.
Tray.
If,
yeah,
if there's not a tip.
Today we had probably five people
holding cameras,
you know what I mean?
Not everybody,
not because it was their job,
but because it was exciting to try and get an interesting frame themselves.
You know,
we wasted everybody on the actual subject matter instead of having somebody
putting powder on our faces.
And there was also,
there wasn't the,
the,
the voice of reason didn't exist.
No.
There was no one person that would know.
Let's say,
look,
we can't do that.
That's too far.
I going to lose our sponsors.
We're going to,
exactly.
I think once you've had the real version,
once you had the uncensored version,
once you've had you on the podcast of you've had me and my show,
it's really hard to ingest us in another format,
you know?
Yeah.
Well it'd be really hard.
It'd be really hard to recreate that,
to like to recreate someone who's really interested in what they're talking
about.
Really passionate about.
It's,
I don't think you can recreate it.
You either into it or you're not.
Yeah.
You can't fake that.
It comes through,
you know,
that's a big issue in mixed martial arts too.
And big image,
mixed martial arts.
Um,
they,
there was a bunch of those sort of sports guys that got into mixed martial arts
and we're doing commentary on it,
but really didn't know what the fuck you're talking about.
But they were more sports and they would say like ridiculous shit.
And the hardcore fans would go crazy.
They go after them,
they're like,
you're not really a fan.
You flip out weird faker guy who doesn't even understand what you're talking
about.
And it just shone through.
And then there's other guys that do it that they big clearly love it.
And those are the ones that are usually embraced.
For the most part.
The only problem from a business perspective is when the guy,
if the guy you're employing knows more about the thing than you do who's really
in the power position,
uh,
you see there's something really enticing about putting a puppet in.
It's true.
Yeah.
And or putting an expert in who will do your bidding or putting,
putting it to,
yeah,
exactly.
An expert the way you see it,
a well compensated experts and those,
that'd be a company man and expert actor.
Yeah.
And then when it comes to electronics and things,
that's when it gets really squirrely because if Sony knows that you've been
beholding to LG and they try to lure you from the LG side and then,
and then LG finds out that you,
well you fucking went over to Sony.
Hi Goddamn.
Turncoat like you,
you've relationships and the whole fucking thing.
Yeah.
How does that work?
Like when you get stuff like I know top gear.
Okay.
You know that show top gear from the baby seat in the show.
Great show,
great show.
Well they had a problem with American,
uh,
would do it on doing it in America because they shit on some cars.
I mean they,
Jeremy Clarkson takes open dumps on some cars.
Emily Porsha's like for years and years until like the nine,
nine,
seven turbo was the first Porsche he praised.
He would shit on them.
How stupid they were.
And they were basically overgrown Beatles and like,
I mean,
it would constantly do that.
And because of that,
like a lot of American car companies didn't want to donate their cars to them
and they had a real issue doing
that show on American TV.
We kind of dipped into that in the last conversation about how when your subject
matter comes from a company,
like if you,
you know,
when you want to go shoot a Romcom movie,
the subject matters that are the actors that you hire.
But in this case,
this,
these are actors,
these are the,
this is what makes the video or breaks the video.
I mean,
I can sit there and talk about what I've heard all I want,
but without it in my hands,
I have no interpretation to share with you.
So it's a very big deal maintaining these relationships and making sure that
you're going to get your hands on this stuff and therefore it is important what
people say and how they say it.
And so this is,
I was ranting last show on tech journalism and somebody had a really good point
in the youtube comments about journalism in general.
They're like,
wait a minute,
think about politics.
Think about commercials on CNN.
I think about the agenda of anybody trying to get a message out there.
If you can shrouded under the heading of journalism,
it's going to get past the filtration system that much easier.
See,
it's the best advertising,
real advertising stuff.
You don't even know it's there.
I like we just said product placement.
I remember when I first found out about product placement,
I think it was on news radio,
they would,
uh,
there's two,
there's different types of product placement and one there's free product that
they just give you free product and so you,
you drink their sodas on the set and you wear their clothes.
Like Nike will give you free sneakers if you're on a television show,
like things along those lines.
There's that kind.
And then there's also like where you are supposed to be holding up a cocacola
while you're in the like,
man,
we've got to find this fucking killer before he kills again.
It's refreshing.
It's really helped me fight crime.
You know,
that's like the low,
the low five version.
That's,
that's like the unsophisticated version of it.
But then on sophisticated version rears its ugly head pretty often.
Sometimes offensively.
Yeah,
on cable TV and the Internet.
Yeah.
The end of that we'll react to internet.
One problem with that shit product place when you fuckhead
Internet won't put up with Shit and,
and ultimately I don't think it functions in nearly as well.
I,
here's the thing,
I always get pissed off when I'm watching a movie or something and they've
completely covered up the logos on everything because watching that movie for me
is all about the suspension of disbelief.
I have to believe that what I'm looking at is potentially
possible,
like if it's an apple laptop of the apple part is blurred out every reality show
ever.
Is that as bad as when it's a Sony show and everyone's got a Sony?
I was watching a movie a day where everyone had Sony,
Sony,
Vaio laptops
right now,
his music videos,
music videos.
It's no longer a viable business.
The investing that much money in a video,
then all you're going to get is a little bit of ad revenue on Youtube,
so they're all supported heavily by private placement.
You'll see beats audio,
you'll see special phones and like super heavy in the frame.
You know,
for me,
if we can all agree that the audiences themselves is becoming more
sophisticated,
we need to get better at hiding the Easter eggs in our entertainment because
you're going to fuck up my suspension of disbelief.
Yeah.
Using them.
So blatantly obvious.
Like I,
like I said with this movie I saw the other day,
the every time they took a photograph it was a Sony Camera.
Every time.
What fucking movie was it?
God dammit.
Yeah,
you need to call this out right now.
Yeah.
I'm trying to remember what movie it is.
I just saw it.
Yeah.
Well here's the problem with the blatant call out is that all of a sudden as a
consumer your guard is up re,
right.
We are bombarded with brand messages on a daily basis and till because of it we
build up this force field.
Right.
That,
I don't know.
I don't remember what the figure is.
You're inundated with thousands of brand messages before you even get to work in
the morning type thing.
Yeah.
And so your guard is up and so it doesn't pass into that other portion of that
subconscious portion of your mind that controls your purchasing decisions.
So not only are you fucking up my entertainment by not allowing for the
suspension of disbelief,
but you're not also,
you're also not selling me your product because I saw what you did there.
Right?
Yeah.
And if I do buy it,
like I'm buying it in spite of what you did because exactly like it's so good.
I'll buy it anyway.
But God,
you idiots.
Oh,
deliver us from evil.
That's what it was.
What's it about?
Oh,
it's a silly fucking movie.
It's supposedly,
it's Eric Bana movie.
It's based on um,
uh,
the real life instances off a New York City police to duck
serious thing where a guy was possessed.
Like,
get the fuck out of here.
It's so ridiculous.
So,
but,
and that had product placement.
It's interesting.
Really blatantly obvious product placement.
It was pretty silly.
Yeah.
Like so much.
So like every time they use the phone you got to see the Sony logo clearly in
place.
And that's see brands themselves,
the people making those calls to the wrong fucking people did the wrong people
that there's just some meeting somewhere in there going,
okay,
we can have the phone in for three frames or eight frames.
We'll take eight frames because we want as much of these as we can get.
Well,
it's not a question of quantity.
It's not,
you just got to plant the seed man.
Well,
if you're teaching them how to be fuckheads,
I don't think you should,
but I don't think that's fuckhead at all because my life experience,
I don't care about average.
Like I,
I personally think good advertising is one of the most sophisticated art forms
that exists,
right?
I have enormous respect for good advertising.
The problem with advertising it,
it's context.
Like for example,
uh,
women,
they are going to read vogue,
Vogue magazine,
right?
Vogue magazine is as much about the people they choose to let advertise in there
as it is about anything they write on their own.
It's all about context,
the experience of picking it up,
going through the pages,
finding things that are attractive and will pulling you in.
And knowing that for three or $4 you are now,
you are now,
uh,
completely consumed in
the culture of all this really expensive stuff in these really expensive brands
and it's all connected.
See their narrative.
The narrative on Vogue magazine is not about what they're putting into it.
It's about who else is there,
who's at the party,
Gucci's their Louis Vuitton is there,
et cetera.
It's about building that entire thing up
and for the male perspective,
dupont registry even better example,
perfect registry is an ad book.
That's right.
You're buying an ad book.
Everything in that magazine is an advertisement and we liked everything and we
love it and it's there at every fucking newsstand.
You see a dupont registry and it's got some new car on.
That's costs way too much fucking money for 99.99,
9% of the people that ever buy that magazine to afford.
That's right.
Probably more than that.
Like the Bugatti Veyron 1,000,005 and it's on the cover and you'll like what?
Who's his magazine for ad for a car that costs more than most people's fucking
houses.
What else is the Robb report?
Yes.
That's another one.
Yeah.
All the Robb report is everything though.
It's like boats and planes.
If vacation homes in Hawaii and all this crazy shit,
but that's the thing.
It's like
ultimately people want to be told what to get,
you know,
we don't have the time.
It's the reason that channels like mine exist.
You don't have the,
there are so many,
the products,
fear is so huge now that keeping tabs on all of it is very difficult to do.
And in some ways we're reverting back to the informational type of advertising
that existed in previous times.
You know,
you break the show and the guy comes out and he goes,
I'm,
I got the new Colgate toothpaste and the host of the show is actually showing
you what it is and what it does.
Seats advertising has moved so far in the abstract direction,
right?
Where it's like you're advertising for beer,
but everyone's partying all the fucking time.
It's like,
what am I buying?
You know,
in a party.
I'm buying a party in a bottle
right by a,
I'm hanging out with these guys that Lou,
their dream come true.
The problem is beer is not representative of the massive sphere that we have to
purchase within.
We needed by complicated shit too.
Right.
And you can't just tell me my life's better
cause I have it.
Well I need,
I need evidence,
man.
That's the place where you come in.
And then Marcus,
um,
anybody who,
that's what he said,
his name,
Marquez,
I say Marquez.
He wound doesn't care if he's Marcus or Marquez M or F if we want to shout out
his channel,
it's Mkbhd
awesome reviews.
Yeah.
Awesome reviews.
But the,
the kind of in depth coverage of electronics does,
did not exist even on like the screen savers even on,
they just couldn't,
there's no way you can,
and no one has that time.
And it's,
it highlights the issues that people have with traditional media.
You know,
it highlights the issues that people have with having a very specific time where
you have to tune into something.
It's true that that was it.
That's a huge barrier to creativity.
Oh,
it's a man,
you have to build this messaging that's suitable for this huge amount of people
at one time.
Like you know the Superbowl,
right?
You spend $1 million for commercial because everybody's paying attention at that
time.
But it's not targeted at all.
Right.
You're not reaching anybody specifically.
I mean,
maybe more dudes are watching it than women though.
I was amazed that the female figures is a lot of women watching it to everyone
in the house is watching it,
but ultimately is part of it is the shotgun approach PR part of it is just
getting the name of your God damned thing to as many people as possible.
But I think real decision making happens at a,
at a much deeper level.
Personally,
that's my feeling.
So awareness is point a,
but uh,
uh,
knowledge is,
is the next step.
So fine.
Make your introduction at the super bowl,
but that's not enough.
You can't stop there.
Yeah.
And I think that also the kind of advertised like the difference between
advertising and informative
entertainment,
which is essentially what you're doing.
I mean you,
when,
when you're doing what I'm doing.
Yeah.
But,
but brands are trying to do what I do now.
Like Samsung will do their own unboxing videos.
Really?
Hell yes.
And who does it for them?
Some random employee.
Rob's,
yeah.
No seriously.
What is,
so it's not major mindblowing.
Look,
look one up later look up to,
I believe it was the s five or the note three.
A Korean girl did it for them.
You're not good.
Not a good job.
It's the whole thing off piece.
It feels the whole thing feels so bizarre.
Again,
again,
you're hitting that,
you're hitting that force field,
you're hitting that sensor.
People are alerted,
you know,
we're all,
that's what I love about it.
I love that sophisticated advertising or something that's a,
that you,
I don't even know if it's just advertising,
but sophisticated content drives a more sophisticated viewer.
I love that.
That all these people out there that experience my content now are going to hold
everything else up to that standard.
You see?
So you can,
you are literally pushing the entire marketplace marketplace by not fitting
within a particular paradigm.
That's so interesting,
man.
And it's also kind of redefining how we view the information that we get on,
on each product.
Like it used to be the only information that you got about a new Chevy truck was
either reading about it in a magazine cause you,
you're so intrigued,
the pickup a Chevy truck magazine or you'd get an ad,
you'd see an ad for a Chevy truck.
Now you go online and you Chevy truck,
everyone knows you.
Everyone does.
And there's so many reviews.
I've been looking at a new SUV.
Why?
My lease is up on my SUV.
I'm just thinking about something else to get or a truck or whatever and I'm
reading all these different views and you get lost man.
It's almost an overload because he'd be like,
look up the Toyota Land Cruiser.
Okay.
The Land Cruiser Binge.
You Binge on cruiser.
He been giant.
How much time did you spend?
Lots of hours.
How much time will you put into this purchase?
Uh,
quite a bit more.
Anything else?
Because it's my,
the family vehicle,
so it's,
I want to make sure they're safe and they're big and they carry all our shit.
If we're going around where seats fold in a million different ways,
big entertainment thing.
So that I have a four year old and a six year old.
They get their little party on the back seat and everything's groovy.
Phone connection,
all the negativity.
The new one,
what's the thing called?
That's carplay.
Carplay.
What's that?
Well that's what,
that's what,
that's what we sort of had that conversation about Google.
They're doing their own version,
but apple has it.
They're eaten car in car software and they have a few automakers,
automakers,
they've aligned with to put essentially an iPhone experience in your dash,
so you no longer have that dumb unit.
You know what they're doing also for a lot of back seats,
they have this thing where you lock in an iPad.
Oh right.
And just his watch pocket.
Just paste it right in there.
The kids watch their IPAD and they also have games that they can play on it.
And they also have their own individual ear jack.
Oh definitely.
Or that's awesome.
Bluetooth within the device.
So they have wireless headphones.
You know,
Mommy and daddy don't have to listen to the fucking frozen for the hundredth
time.
That's thinking about kids,
man.
It's cute.
It's adorable.
But once they love something,
they just want to watch it over and over and over and over and over.
I went through tangled.
I went through a period of watching tangled.
I probably saw it a hundred times,
probably.
So that yet.
No,
no.
Minor American.
Different than yours.
My kids are different.
Definitely have different DNA.
No,
they're not.
You.
I know.
Mine.
My two year old especially.
You got to remember they had like,
they'd had all the technology,
all the video games since day one.
So no Waldorf School for your kid.
Fuck No.
Do you know about Waldorf School?
They make you play with the wooden toys?
I had a friend who went there.
Yeah.
No electronics.
No,
no.
None of that.
Nice kids.
Well,
that's subjective.
Nicest a subjective word,
right.
I agree.
Um,
but no,
listen,
I'm immersed in it.
I want to connect with them.
How am I,
in fact,
will's been in a bunch of my videos my four year old lately.
Uh,
which is amazing because half of the shit he sees it come in the house,
you know,
and,
and he doesn't get to participate in that part of it.
So I think I have the,
in that sense,
I have the coolest job.
I get to do shit with him,
but,
um,
and most of it,
and every time it's him driving it,
not me.
So for the audience,
it's like you're exploiting him or whatever.
This is him nagging me weeks on end.
Let's make another video.
Four years old likes it.
He loves it.
He is fun.
But they're so into this world that,
uh,
like youtube for example,
they give them an iPad.
They know how to navigate youtube.
And this is the craziest part,
and I,
and I've talked about this before as well.
It's like the consumption thing that I'm in,
like the product world,
the tech world,
it exists for different spectrums to like makeup and beauty and kids.
Shit,
Ma,
they research their toys,
man.
They researched the stuff they want.
Yeah.
So they were watching Plato sets.
They're watching car sets.
They're watching Lego,
Lego man.
So they're getting started even earlier than me.
Not only that,
those toys get reviewed and that's right.
The star rating system.
That's right.
I'll give you go to Amazon and you look up children's toys,
you'll see a rating system and comments at the parents and the children will
even like tell the parents what they like or don't like about a toy.
And the parents talk about like this failed quality,
which she used to.
I used to have to like read consumer reports or find out,
right
if it was even safe or dangerous toys that broken stabbed you and you felt,
Oh uh,
the high chairs recall a fucking high chair cause people are falling over or
whatever.
Now all that shit's out in the open.
It's amazing.
You see.
But here's the thing,
it's like if,
if the blockbuster guys are on one end of the spectrum,
poor fucking blockbuster guys,
I keep on calling them out,
they still exist.
Those are real guys that are listening right now.
Probably not poor bastards.
Anyway.
If the blockbuster guys are on one end of the spectrum and my kids are on the
other because I'm already completely sensitized to the traditional media
messaging,
like it's not going to fucking work on me.
It sure as fuck isn't going to work on them.
Yeah,
they know how to get around it.
Not only that,
they're from the Joe.
How old are you?
29 I'm 46 right,
so obviously I dealt with a lot of years where there was no influence
whatsoever.
Exactly.
By the common person with social media and the ability to spread information
like a guy like you didn't exist when I was young,
my job didn't exist when I was in high school.
My guidance counselor couldn't have told me what the fuck I was going to be
doing cause youtube wasn't even a thing.
He probably wouldn't have told you to do it anymore.
Guide what guidance counselors can I tell you,
hey man,
you should make some youtube videos.
I get that question more than anything else from young people.
How do I do what you do?
It's a number one question.
It just start doing it right.
That's it.
I mean,
those people that are asking that question,
knuckleheads,
stop with the questions.
Just go do something.
That's the problem with people.
They like to talk about shit so much.
They don't actually do shit.
I've been reading Stephen King's book on writing,
which is a great book.
Or I was reading it this weekend and I'm one of the great things about the book
and he says like,
don't even talk about writing so much.
Like you should just go.
Right.
Just get it done.
Like in a lot of times people,
and this is also in Steven Pressfield's book,
the war of art.
A lot of times people will distract themselves from the actual work at hand by
talking about it.
Some definitely.
No,
I mean,
I completely feel that way.
In fact,
in my studio,
I tried to create it in such a fashion where the friction between me starting
something and not starting something,
is that the lowest level possible?
You've done the same thing here,
obviously.
I mean,
Jesus,
you just sit down and go,
yeah,
you know,
and that's the key.
Because human beings,
we will naturally find ways out of doing.
Yeah,
we know we're supposed to be doing,
but this is easy to do.
This is like at all the things that I do that require me to do it.
Whether it's writing,
being the most difficult,
standup being the least difficult.
This is the easiest standup being the least if oh to get me to do.
Oh,
okay,
I got a lot of doing standup.
It's really fun.
Right.
You know,
it's probably the most difficult to get right.
This is probably the easiest out of all the things that I do.
I don't know that all things that I do,
it might be to you,
but I mean to the average person,
I think this format is,
it requires a certain openness about yourself because to do a set,
are you re,
are you revealing as much about yourself and a comedy set as you are in a three
hour conversation?
You definitely may reveal more than a three hour conversation,
I would think.
I would think so too.
You can,
especially when you do 500 of them.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah,
that's me get a sense and a lot of people I know the barrier that's holding them
back in the first place is insecurity about who they are or what they have to
share or whether or not anyone gives a fuck.
Well,
it,
that's a much tougher place to put them in this seat where they're expected to
show who they are for three hours instead of mastering this really perfect
little box,
this little thing that represents them.
Right?
Like I think,
uh,
I make most of my videos are three to five minutes long and I think a person
could listen to this podcast right here and know more about me than if they
watched 500 of them.
Oh,
most certainly.
What's the longest you've ever done a video for?
Anything that's like really complex that warrants a much longer,
you know,
you can get up into like 10,
15,
maybe 15,
like what would it be?
15 like a new phone or something like really competent kind of comparison like
something versus something else.
But you don't like limit yourself like you,
well there's this it.
Listen if you're getting,
you had to be smart in anything that you,
that you do if you're investing a lot of time in it and so there is definitely a
retention issue.
We,
if we're willing to identify the fact that consumption habits are changing and
the web is the driving force behind that and we also need to be cognizant of the
fact that we need to fit within a certain fit within certain boundaries.
Even though those boundaries are loose and no one's going to fucking tell you
one way or the other.
A lot of the conversations I have in brainstorming that I do is about
hyper-focusing and iterating and finding better ways of reaching people and we
just,
I think a lot of us,
I'm speaking I guess for the community as a whole have figured out that three to
five minutes is just what makes sense.
Three to five minutes is a song length as well.
Yeah,
it's a really weird,
it's really weird that it lines up that way.
Three minutes is what they say.
Right.
You see like something
for sure.
Something weird.
We don't have a youtube up there right now,
but if you look at the youtube interface,
it's a lot of thought goes into the way things are laid out.
People freak out whenever anything changes.
And why the fuck is that?
Their Google stupid people love seeing the shit like that.
Yeah.
Youtube does a pretty decent job of setting up.
Like if you watch click on one of those videos,
Brian,
like one of your videos,
you would look on the right and you get suggested stuff.
Others.
Yeah,
that's,
that's what sends you down those rabbit holes.
That's where shit gets weird.
But here's the,
so here's the thing about this frame right now that we're looking at,
at what point does this video become less enticing than the juicy shit on the
right,
right.
He say he Fullscreen did,
so he kind of killed it.
But full screening,
it definitely does Fullscreen and it does.
Right?
But why is it youtube not by default,
a Fullscreen interface?
Well,
because they're about view times as a whole.
Can we talk about this last time?
Did that,
did we?
I don't remember,
but that totally makes sense.
The way they're designed.
I think it's the perfect design.
Also the comments as a name and retarded and fucking aggravating as they can be.
They engage people and get people to spend more time participate.
There's some folks that just do not have an outlet and I think that's sometimes
reflected in the angry and anger and vitriol that you see exhibited on a youtube
page.
It's not even representative oftentimes of what they're actually reviewing.
It's,
it's a reflection of their own life is that people don't feel like they are
heard.
They don't feel like they matter.
They don't feel like they have a voice.
And then finally when they do have a voice,
like
what they're saying is no one wants to fuck me.
My boss is an asshole.
I picked the shitty career.
You know,
I don't like where I live.
Sort of feel like people within those communities don't get enough recognition
though.
So like which communities,
so like my,
let's say my best viewers,
let's say your best viewers,
anyone's the best.
They're all the same to me,
the fuck out of my awesome people.
Get it on my face right now.
How dare you.
Listen,
there are people who are fucking Joe Rogan diehards.
Those people matter more to you than the hundred thousands,
100,000 others that are fair weather type viewers.
They're evangelists for you.
They're out there saying to their buddies,
you fucking hear the podcast.
Go check out the podcast.
You need to hear this podcast.
Check out this guest he had on so on and so forth.
Don't tell them they're important.
Then they're going to want more attention and then to know what are you doing?
No locking up everything.
There's a way that there's a way this can work,
the way that it can work.
Yeah,
mushrooms and everybody's got to get on mushrooms together at the same time,
I don't know.
Here's how it works.
We need to find a way to reward the most important in our own communities.
Okay?
Because here's why.
It's not fair that they're out there as evangelists for our brands and yet they
get nothing out of it.
What are you talking about?
They get the entertainment out of it.
That's the whole exchange.
That's fine.
Other than the entertainment,
then it changes and morphs.
That's fine if they get the entertainment out of it,
but so to somebody else who shuts the fuck up immediately after they watch it,
the part they're doing on their own time is not about the entertainment anymore.
Right.
But she don't,
you do that as well and don't I do that as well and do what he,
but you talk about things that you enjoy and the,
the benefit of that is that you support the things that you enjoy.
Like game of Thrones for instance,
evangelists of game of Thrones.
You can't stop talking.
They've never paid me wouldn't did I say pay?
What do you mean by reward?
There are ways to recognize without necessarily paying somebody like who's,
let's put it this way.
Who's your most engaged Twitter follower?
Who Do you talk to more than anyone else?
I don't think I have a one.
You probably do know,
but I'd done saying have one.
We don't have inaccurate.
We don't have an accurate way of figuring out.
I would like,
you know what would be interesting to me to know who has tweeted at Joe Rogan
more than any other user going to attract a psych?
Oh No,
it's me.
I am the one I am Highlander.
You're essentially sending out a bat signal to crazy people.
No,
no,
I'm not going all crazy beyond not because in the real world stuff like this has
existed for the longest time.
Like take for example a forum.
A forum is not in the real world,
but it's an older platform in a,
in a forum.
Game of Thrones sent me a box that counts.
That fucking counts.
By the way.
It's true.
Well they did that after I talked about them for that fucking counts.
They didn't just send it just to me either,
by the way.
Okay.
No,
no,
I know.
But like what are you talking about?
Like in what way would you reward them?
So what do you got planned in the old days?
On a forum forum in the old days,
but what all did he,
mine has been around since 1998 I thought I had the oldest form on the net or
it's one of the oldest forms to me.
When I get in a forum,
I feel like I'm in the old internet.
Okay.
And the reason is because social media to me has sort of sort of absorbed some
of what forms are used to be for socializing.
Right?
Right.
So I kind of look at social networks.
It's like forum 2.0 or whatever.
Right?
But Anyway,
forum still exists and that's cool.
But on a forum,
the people who participate like crazy,
in some forums they have,
they have like five stars or something,
or they're a reps,
a contributor or wrap,
a moderator,
Ma like moderators take lots of pride in being moderators,
even though they're not getting paid to be moderators right now,
granted,
you can have circumstances where things get fucking creepy and weird.
That's,
that's going to happen.
That's inevitably going to happen.
But for each one of them,
there's a hundred cool people who want to participate in your community and just
get a little bit of recognition for that participation.
I really want to know who has tweeted at unbox therapy therapy more than anyone
else.
I wonder who that person is.
Not because,
not because I want to stock them,
but because I want to find a way to thank them for stalking you.
So you think you're making,
you're taking the totally negative approach on this.
I can't help but it's very optimistic.
Be Optimistic.
Normally you're the optimistic one right on the podcast and the,
the person in this seat is the pessimistic one.
Not necessarily,
but I think that w I agree in form of what you're saying.
Um,
but I think that what the,
the beauty and the purity of the relationship between someone who likes your
show and someone comments on your show,
someone who enjoys you show is that your show gets more recognition,
more hits and it continues to grow and they get better content because they
enjoy it,
they enjoy it,
it makes their life interesting.
You know,
I try as much as possible like when I'm on,
if you look at my Twitter,
one of the things that is about my Twitter that's important to me is anything
that I find that's interesting online I share,
right?
So not everything because he would be as non box therapy on a constant stream.
I put that I'm just fucking around dairy,
but it would be a constant stream of videos and content I can't do,
I can't do everything,
but things that I think are fascinating like um,
or important.
Like,
uh,
I put up something on from science magazine about a widespread contamination of
the marine environment by microplastics,
which I think is really a sad and remember of course,
yeah,
you know,
reversible but needs to be addressed.
Part of our society and the use of plastics in our relationship with the oceans.
Thinking along those lines,
um,
sexy photos on Facebook may cause women to be seen as less competent.
That's from the science world report.
That's another thing that I tweeted.
Fascinating.
Right?
Yeah.
Interesting.
So I put a lot of that online.
So I feel like that is you're adding value for people.
Yeah,
definitely.
And it's awesome.
It gives them an incentive also,
selfishly to tweet me these interesting things so that I retweet them because I
do that all the time to followers.
Yeah,
a lot of followers and recognition and people,
you know,
people like,
well,
that's a perfect,
that's a perfect example.
I mean,
that's part of the reason that I love Twitter is that you,
they know you see them,
but seeing youtube comments,
I mean,
you can reply.
It's impossible to reply to everyone,
but on Twitter you see one,
one guy gets retweeted,
you think,
well,
I could get retweeted at some point later.
Something that's been a big conversation lately is the favorite button.
Are you a fan of the favorite button?
No,
it doesn't make any sense to me.
Yeah.
Well,
it doesn't make a lot of sense to a lot of people.
People use it for different reasons.
Some people use it to save tweets,
but that's not the way I use it at all.
I could care less about saving tweets.
Most of the time I could use it that way.
But the majority of how I use it as a recognition piece.
So you are cool.
You sent me some cool shit.
I can't retweet it right now,
but I see you.
But why?
Why can't you retweet it?
It's just as easy to press retweet and it's just depressing because ultimately
you need to curate your feed.
If you retweet everything,
everyone's ends you,
you're fucked.
Right?
But if you sit a Cylance feed and favorites,
no mom,
no.
So like,
so what I mean no favors.
Well favorite to do come up,
but it's kind of,
you have to go there to get it right.
Meaning if you favorite,
something is not going to go on your feet.
Right.
So a favorites are a little tougher to get your hands on.
I see what you're saying.
So you're letting someone know that you see them,
you give them a response by favoriting their tweet,
but you don't put it on your feed so they can,
they know that you see them.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Actually.
That's the best use of it that I've ever heard.
I do it as a bookmark.
That's how it was.
That's what it was intended for.
Yeah.
That's how I've used it.
That's the only way I've,
I've intended as a bookmark and there's this growing group of people.
I don't know how many,
but when I talk about it on Twitter,
a lot of people said they're doing the same thing.
It's a movement to try and generate essentially a like button on Twitter where
it doesn't exist.
Okay,
so the favorite becomes a like button sort of.
I liked that.
I liked that because I can actually use that way more because the way I use it
now,
I just,
I just don't,
I can't,
there's no way I can know.
You can't name that comes my way.
Even see everything that comes your way.
No,
but if you're sitting on Twitter and somebody takes the effort to to like they
thought of you,
they saw this cool thing,
they thought of you,
you hit the star button and it's like there's an exchange.
There are,
there is some recognition.
It's not a dollar value,
but that's the kind of stuff I'm talking about.
I'm talking about nurturing a community.
That makes sense.
That totally makes sense.
And then that,
um,
I think nurturing and community also comes from being engaged from reading your
comments and maybe commenting on them in another podcast or another,
a video cast,
whatever you would like to call it.
Or um,
Twitter,
you know,
engaging with people as much as possible,
answering questions as much as possible.
But with me,
there's a certain balance of engaging and still getting work done.
Like my,
my thing is all about producing content.
I produce,
yeah.
Hours of a podcast.
Yeah,
three days a week,
most of the time.
And then there's the writing of comedy and have random thoughts that that have
to take place.
If it doesn't take place,
my common you'll suffer.
And probably my conversations that I have on podcasts will suffer.
I need to think about ideas by myself as well as have them in a conversation
with people.
And then there's also the researching of Shit,
the reading of articles,
the watching of documentaries,
the reading of magazines or books.
The amount of time that's leftover to just engage with people online is pretty
minimal.
And if you change the balance in any way,
all the content that you put out suffers.
Right.
And I think it's easy to forget that the content in and of itself is a
communication.
Yes.
Meaning that like it's,
it's similar to what I said before about the best buy thing.
How essentially we took a traditional model of this guy in his best buy store
and we said this is much more dynamic and it's much more streamlined to take one
guy who really knows and give that to everyone.
Well,
video is this way of having one message suitable or sent to hundreds,
thousands,
millions of people.
Whereas it's a personalized tweet.
I'm sorry.
If you were to sit there all day and answer every tweet you ever got,
you'd never make another thing in your life.
Exactly.
And ultimately the reason people care about you in the first place is because of
all the cool shit you made.
Yeah,
there's a balance.
it's an,
it may be,
who knows?
Maybe it's like a weekly asked me anything sort of a thing like they do on
reddit.
Oh yeah,
he's read it.
Definitely kind of fun.
Some of the guys that we had with us,
big proponents of asking me videos as well and you just,
you get thousands of questions and on Twitter and you pick a few and addressing.
It's huge.
Yeah.
And I think that might be a better way to do it even because writing things like
one of the issues that I have with blog entries,
and I do enjoy reading people's blogs,
but one of the issues that I have is that you,
if you give someone a free,
you know,
a page where it's just an open platform to write things and to write about a
subject,
they're not opposed,
you know,
it's just their thoughts and it's a way to express thoughts.
But they might be saying some incorrect,
incorrect and not factual shit or distorted shit.
And they use that as the base for other statements and they use that as a base
to further expand upon these thoughts that were based almost entirely on
something incorrect in the first place or distorted in the first place were
biased in the first place.
So it creates this piece like say if someone was writing something about you,
like a really bias piece about Lewis from unbox helping.
Thanks for giving him the idea.
You know what I'm saying?
They did do that and a lot of it was based on some incorrect assumptions about
you as some incorrect information or distorted perception probably exists.
Sure.
I'm sure it does.
But my point being that that's a really bad way to communicate ideas.
It's good for just trying to shame someone or trying to,
uh,
you know,
just throw mud on their name,
but,
or to pray someone or to pump someone up and create them,
create some art.
But the best way to express an idea is to have that idea sort of vetted out with
another person.
Yeah.
You know,
and that,
that doesn't really,
that I,
that doesn't really happen when you do it in that form.
No.
Yeah.
And,
and another thing too,
like,
well building on that is the fact that video in and of itself is the closest
thing we have to real life to actually meeting somebody.
Yes.
So you can,
you know,
you can take all of those things that are happening within communication that
aren't necessarily the words themselves and you can put those into the overall
sort of scenario and the line that you're going to draw based on their
perspective.
You guys were talking recently about,
uh,
your buddy on Twitter who had the radio show and said some stuff and then got
kicked off the radio show and yeah.
And you know,
con to how context in so many ways dictates interpretation.
So if video is the best right videos,
this modern form of communication and writing his fucking super old,
you look at the,
you will,
first of all,
one of them is way better.
But look at the reason why writing was invented.
Writing was invented because he didn't have,
well,
I wonder what was your alternative?
Right.
But I don't think it's way better.
Well,
because I think writing's has its place definitely for some things,
right?
Yeah.
I don't think I agree with you.
I don't think it's a question of better or worse.
But look what television did to newspapers.
Yeah.
Or the web did to newspapers,
right?
So it's one,
it's not better or worse or it's,
maybe it's the comic book discussion all over again.
Something will win out.
It will happen.
It is TV better for people.
The newspapers,
it doesn't really matter anymore.
It's a moot point because people chose TV.
Right.
But that's just because it's passive.
He just sit there.
That's right.
And it just comes to you when given the choice between video.
Here's something that Google's testing is,
instead of giving you text based search results on a Google search,
they give you video results.
They give you,
you can you Google something and there's a video option for Google to serve up.
They'll grab it.
That's a lot of my traffic comes from Google search,
not youtube searches.
So Google knows that their objective is to answer your question in the way that
you want to have it answered.
That makes sense,
right?
The bet.
The most suitable format for you to ingest.
And oftentimes that means video because retention times are better on video.
People,
I don't want to say are lazy people,
just like sophisticated delivery models or like documentaries for me are an
amazing way to learn.
Well,
it's also you can't hide when if someone writes something in print,
but they're full of shit.
It's hard.
Yeah.
It's hard to see that posing less about themselves.
How much would you like if you ever read,
like you ever read a really crazy tumbler site,
right?
And you're like,
oh my God,
I would so much rather hear you say this.
You know like,
oh,
like some crazy radical feminists ranting anti male ran to.
Here's the thing about that too is when you write something,
it's not,
it's nothing like plastering your face on something.
I think these people wouldn't say half the shit they said if it was their face
in front of every most likely.
Yeah.
And so if you would expose the craziness would come out of it,
you would see it.
He goes,
oh,
you're a fucking banana.
Oh,
sorry,
I need,
I can stop watching this now.
Now I know what I'm dealing with or I can watch this with a more level
perspective.
That's why I'm saying that's what I'm saying.
Video is the ultimate,
the ultimate in terms of bits and bytes.
Think about the information.
I write down on a bunch of shit on his notepad.
If I were to put that into bits and bytes,
take a photograph or type it out.
That's nothing at and can SMS message in terms of size is not,
there's not very much data there.
You know it's true.
If I want.
That's what held the web back.
That's why newspapers exist.
That's why we had to send each other letters.
We didn't have the bandwidth.
Ah,
now that we have the bandwidth,
we can transport ourselves.
The closest thing we can get to it across the other way and so we have to stand
up for the shit that we actually believe in.
We have to be authentic.
We have to all these other things immediately fall into line because it's so
much harder to fake when you have access to all that extra data.
Well then how come like a sort of 15 second thing on on Twitter hasn't taken off
like 140 character thing.
Like a 15 second video thing.
Oh,
like fine and shit.
Yeah,
like
kind of silly.
Yeah.
Instagram is pretty big though.
Right.
But I mean,
how many people express themselves on it?
They have videos where they do things like they'll skip forward jump Wu or
they'll fucking ride a motorcycle.
Woo.
You know,
they'll have that.
But how many of them are of people staring at the camera and saying something
for 140 care,
440 characters.
You know,
here's a huge community.
I mean Instagram taking a Manga.
I know,
but then Instagram is mostly pictures,
mostly pictures with context underneath it.
How many?
Why?
What if we're talking about the purest expression,
the closest thing you can get to an actual person for the actual video like
this,
why isn't that taking off?
Whereas a pure video communication,
youtube vine be up at 15 seconds.
Why does,
why do you care?
Why do you want it to be 15 yeah,
that's what I know it.
That's fine.
But I know that because of like one of the things that made Twitter stand out.
Oh,
40 courses concision I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
So can we force concision with video?
Okay.
Is that possible?
What we're talking about ultimate expression,
right?
The ultimate experience of somebody and who they are and what they are.
What you do over here,
three hours you kick me.
If we're agreeing that it's all about faking it or not faking it,
it's only going to get astronomically harder the longer you have to hold it up.
Right.
I agree with that,
but what I'm saying is a takeout that I,
I definitely agree that to get a cross,
a more elaborate point of view,
right.
Discuss something in depth.
You would want a youtube video.
That's the benefit of youtube,
but like what about a something where I guess a lot of Twitter is a sharing of
links,
but take away the sharing of links.
What's your new Captain American movie today?
All my God,
did it suck a fat Dick gone.
That's it.
Vine.
But do they use it for that?
Yeah.
People use it for that.
Most of vine is like comedy stuff.
The vast majority people joking around,
little tiny seven second skits.
Right?
Like some of the popular ones that I've recognized is this thing where people
really like Jordan shoes.
I don't know,
you probably maybe saw this past around where if a guy's really into sneakers,
he,
if he gets us a little mark on his Jordans,
he freaks out,
you know,
that kind of paradigm or that kind of whatever,
whatever that is.
So that's like a thing.
But on vine there's,
there's some channels that are dedicated to that.
Like what I would do,
I don't know really,
but funny,
in a funny way,
whatever is skit,
I'm doing a terrible job of describing it.
You use vine all the time.
Like I was pretty much reviewing Spiderman three when I was watching it using
vine and Instagram and stuff like that while you were watching it.
So I think,
yeah,
I think there's an issue right now of expectations and I think that when a
person logs on to Twitter,
they have obvious expectations of what there's,
what's going to be there,
the context of it,
and I think that for right now,
youtube is synonymous with video right now and it's going to be difficult for
any player at any length to come in there and change it.
I started taking pictures,
tweets of drawings of a,
of writings rather than I made.
I just thought I was going to do it for the rest of my tweets from now on.
It's just even a picture of shit that I wrote down so people could see my
handwriting,
but I only did it once.
Yeah.
Well it was like,
this is stupid.
Well,
the way I look at a right thing,
well not only that,
but the problem is there that a lot of what makes the web so good in finding
shit you care about is the fact that text is searchable.
Yeah.
You take a picture,
all that data's gone.
That's true.
But what I was going to say is how infuriating would it be to people if you made
a youtube video of a bunch of shit you wrote like page after page of things you
wrote.
That was the thing was,
is really the people super depressed people.
Oh,
it says,
oh,
I see they don't have a voice.
And then you turn the page.
Oh,
ah,
yeah.
Did you ever see that one where a woman,
uh,
left a job and she wrote this a the page after page,
like a tumbler thing of all these cards,
like shitting on her boss.
And then so the boss wrote back and did the same forms.
Yeah,
I signed the form and she was dancing around and shit to annihilated or yeah.
she will.
She was wearing like sexy outfits and stuff like that.
And he was talking about how fucking stupid she was.
Incompetent and a bad employee and selfish.
That's interesting.
When precede people take old tech and introduce it into a new format.
The reason that they're doing it is because they're trying to imply,
I don't know if they try and make it more serious than it is,
but ultimately I think it's because that person is not the best at expressing
themselves in the real form.
Well,
that's weird because the original version of that was Bob Dylan.
Dylan would that song,
what was that song that he did that there was a music video,
an old Bob Dylan success did it.
I've seen it.
Do you think Bob Dylan was great at expressing himself?
Oh yeah.
You don't think he was great at expressing himself?
No.
See,
but I appreciate abstract a representation,
but it's,
it's not the same as sitting in a room with somebody.
Right.
We never sat in a room with Bob Dylan.
That's true.
That's good point.
But that was his art form was expressing himself through music,
did a great lyric,
a great job there.
You know,
and if you look at,
look at the lyrics and whatnot,
incredibly sophisticated and deep and meaningful and all the rest of it.
But I think,
I don't know,
I'm drawing a separation myself.
I think art has always been a way for those,
for people to communicate in a format that's more comfortable for them.
You're going to go,
you're going to go to their party.
They're not going to come to yours.
Talking is something we all have to do.
Right.
You know it's,
it's interesting as well is if you went back to Bob Dylan's heyday,
you went to the 60s and the 70s and said,
okay,
we're going to make short films where you just talk about shit and then people
could take it and watch it and be like,
it seems it seems brutal,
right?
He's terrible.
It like why would rather just
do a song?
It's like,
why would we want our,
why would we want our Bob Dylan in that form?
But it's the same for celebrities nowadays.
It's like once upon a time a celebrity was like vapor.
Like what are they doing in their spare time now?
Charlie Sheen arguing with his ex wife on.
Yeah,
exactly.
Do they eat cheerios?
Like what is like,
are they real?
You know,
but now it's,
this exposure in so many ways has forced them to be real people at for us and we
can shit all over them,
you know?
Well this shitting all over him also.
We have the access
shit.
That's right.
And,
and again,
it's much like the traditional brand thing coming into youtube.
It's like the traditional people have to come to our party now you see they just
got a profile like anyone else.
Well sort of.
And then there's people that exploit that opening.
Like if you have a good article,
a TMZ article about Kim and Kanye that is essentially a portal for hate.
That's all that is.
What that exists is you open up the comments and then just let the floodgates of
hell just open up on the photo of Kim and Kanye kissing in front of some fucking
fountain somewhere.
So it's a fucked up to me that people give a shit about that give a shit what I,
it's probably second only to porn.
Wow.
If you thought about like the amount of internet space,
it's used to just shit on random targets of hate.
Whether it's like some ridiculous celebrities like it used to be Paris Hilton
and that bitch just evaporated piece.
She vanished.
Well,
realize that piggy backing on that is so fucking low.
Who the people that are commenting or the people that are bald of it,
all of it.
Well,
the people that are making it was TMZ or any of these.
They're making a lot of money and it's,
it's a,
if you ever seen,
there's a,
Morgan Spurlock has that show inside.
Man.
You ever see that show?
No.
I've seen these documentaries though.
Good show.
Um,
it's on CNN and he does a bunch of different jobs like in just,
we'll go inside and see what it's like to be different people's lives.
And one of them he did was he hung out with a bunch of Paparazzi and the way
they see it,
it's like,
look,
this is a Gig.
You know,
you wanted to be famous.
You know what?
Let's leave them out.
Let's go boil it down all the way to the consumption because that's what drives
everything else.
That's,
that's the fuel,
right?
Why is it,
why is that something that human beings want to consume?
Because it's fascinating.
Why is that fast as stupid as fuck.
Cause why?
Why does it matter?
Why does it matter what Kim Kardashians and Kanye West are doing it?
It's actually been studied by sociologists and they,
our conclusion is that gossip was a way of keeping monitoring behavior and the
sort of reactions to our own behavior and how people perceived us in the
community.
And it's sort of to elevate themselves by trial and error.
Where we talked about earlier,
learning from your mistakes.
Well those mistakes sometimes or socially being ostracized,
your act,
so your words or you know,
those things existed in communities.
Kind of keep people in check.
Well now we live in communities where I've been in the same house for 10 years.
I barely know my fucking neighbors,
dude.
I mean barely.
I wait.
There's a few people in my neighborhood that I'm pretty friendly with that I've
seen over the Times that we've had conversations.
But we don't hang out.
We don't want,
no one's knocking on my door and coming over for dinners.
You know this,
we have these weird environments that we live in now and we have this desire to
find out what everyone else is up to.
And the only real way to do that is through gossip.
And when there's no gossip,
you just go to the gossip of the kings and Queens,
who is the kings and Queens movie stars,
Rock Stars,
those people that you see in her low fees and form of communication though.
Well,
but so compelling.
So then it becomes,
well,
if it's so low,
why do so many people engage in it?
What is the draw?
What is the,
there's some sort of base human attraction to finding out what tiger woods
texted to all those freaky bitches on his,
uh,
his hit list.
You know,
there's some strange thing to finding out about,
I guess it makes people feel better about themselves.
It seems excited finding out some dirt.
Right?
But at the same time they can point and say,
you're the fucked up one,
so my life's more normal,
or my life's better.
Well,
it takes the focus on the fucked up.
They never,
when Britney spears was like imploding or whatever it was head and went navy and
it was an opportunity for people to point and say,
look how fucking crazy she is.
The photos of her with a fucking umbrella wielding it.
Photographers Agley.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
definitely makes you,
especially when it's that bad.
When do you remember David Hasselhoff has daughter released a video of him
unbelievably drunk,
like scrounging.
Yes,
I do a hamburger.
I recall that it was so insane.
You see this poor fucking side throws of sick.
I see shit like scrambling up food like that and she shit like that as traps.
Like if I'm on the web,
that's like a bear trap to me.
I know it stuck in it.
You know that that bay link Bait and shit.
Yeah.
If you see the web,
he's consumed in these tidbits and all you need to do is grip a p a person on
the lowest common denominator and you win.
And it's like if the consumers themselves don't man the fuck up and see a trap
when it's there and not click on it,
you know,
I mean obviously it's,
it's obviously a discussion that you're not,
you can't get to the bottom of,
but it's like you are essentially supporting the kind of shit you don't really,
like.
I was reading this thing on pornography recently or watching,
this thing's a ted talk on pornography.
Somebody sent it to me on Twitter and they said this guy is the biggest white
night ever.
And I expected it to be just like a tumbler website were some dude was like
arguing about being a male feminist or something.
Some along those lines.
But it was a guy who actually made these like pretty intense detailed points
about what's the,
the real issue with watching pornography.
And it was pretty because it was
really in depth.
Hmm.
And he was talking about a lot of shit that's,
you know,
pretty undeniable and uniquely undeniable.
Like one of the things he was talking about is that the,
that a lot of sex in porn is nothing like sex in real life in that there's no
hands and what he meant was there's no caressing and massaging,
rubbing and holding and all the thing that people do when they make love they,
they make love.
Notice how I said that,
and very sensitive.
Instead it's like the people that are doing things at odd angles.
He was a little white in it for sure,
but there's a,
it's undeniable that when you take no,
don't just have this idea in your head and it might be something wrong with
watching porn,
but have it so much so that you've concocted a Ted talk and you know you're
presented yourself as this moral alternative,
this moral and ethical alternative to all the other men out there.
This is certainly like a progressive brownie point,
sort of a pull of that initiative.
Did something regarding the pornography thing though that I think is interesting
and maybe a reason why from a discussion standpoint there is something there is
because at once upon a time the consumption of porn,
I dunno when I was a kid,
I guess I don't know because I sorta missed it.
You had to physically go and get it to video tape or for
end magazine.
I'll tell you son,
cause I was around back then when I was young,
they had video stores and this was before blockbuster even took off.
It was mom and pop video stores and you would go to these local video stores and
you know,
I still have to watch you walk into the bag.
Sometimes you have memberships to these videos,
stores,
remember those and you had a card and they would punch your card.
And every 10th video you've got to fucking discount or free video.
Um,
there was,
uh,
like you would push beads aside or like saloon doors and you would go into this
area and it was all chicks and fucking ass isn't,
and mostly not like really hardcore shit like you're seeing today.
Like they would actually like the covers of these,
these videos would sort of be concocted knowing that they were going to be
placed on a shelf somewhere.
It's so much could kind of just get to as opposed to typing in,
you know,
suck my cock.com or whatever the hell it is and you're going to go right there.
So you know what to expect.
American pornography consumption pre-internet.
Post-Internet well I think it's a lot like our gossip consumption.
We have access to it,
we're going to consume more of it.
But the amplification level on porn,
I think he's like nothing else.
I think it's like both of them.
I think both of them have massive amplification levels because you access,
let's put it this way,
but you could always go to a grocery store and walk out the door with a gossip
magazine.
Super easy access,
eat the saloon door thing.
I mean there's like what?
Two into every town and it's was,
it was in a corner somewhere.
That's true.
But it's,
but magazine is very finite,
you know?
Maybe there's two or three of them on the shelf.
Yeah.
Your daughter.
When you get from front to back and you had to stop consuming it.
There's not a lot of stuff there aren't there are parallels there.
I mean I think probably the pornography one,
I think both of them are based on human incentive.
Fucking similar.
They're both based on,
so how about this gossip is porn for girls?
For Women.
Huh?
But it's not I,
yeah,
I don't think it is pouring.
Well this is obviously still porn for women,
but you know,
I'll tell you one thing you can be sure of if there's a man who's really into
gossip,
that guy's a bitch.
That's a fact.
If there's a man out there who's really into like this girl shoes or that girls
dress and look at her stupid car like
I think there's,
I think there's gossip.
I think guys and girls like gossip for the same reason that like if you go to a
movie and you're,
you like Brad Pitt movies,
you also want to know what Brad Pitt's doing it in real life.
Like is he getting,
doing drugs and,
but that's only if drink,
like someone who's a movie star.
When you talk about Kim and Kim Kardashians and her family,
they don't,
they don't do anything.
They miss rappers ever later that he's a recent addition to that fucking circus.
I'm going to use this opportunity to go for that.
Yeah,
please do.
Before that there was nothing.
I mean if you stop to think about it,
cheap contributed nothing.
All she was doing was being a point of gossip.
So in that sense,
she's way bigger gossip star than any Angelina Jolie's story.
You know the,
if you looked at the number of people that are paid attention to Kim Kardashians
versus paying attention to Angelina Jolie,
I bet I'd be willing to better like five or six to one and Kim's favorite.
So I think it's more of Oh look at her and if you can do things to keep eyes on
you,
that's your business.
Whether it's hate or love your business is to keep that.
That's sort of weird.
Gossipy energy up.
Yeah.
I mean I,
I go to it every day to watch because it's,
you go to watch TMZ and stuff like that.
I'll,
I love,
I love that shit.
Cause it's just like all my God,
look what happened here.
Look what happened there.
You know?
And it's just because you watch them on TV and you watch them in movies and like
make believe world.
And so it's weird seeing them outside of make believer of what the,
Oh shit.
Tom Cruise's got aids,
you know,
so I mean allegedly,
but that's not even true.
And where that big gold medal around his neck,
by the way,
do you follow Yoko Ono on Twitter?
Of course.
Yeah,
of course.
Mammary.
Put it in a box,
burn the box and sprinkled the ashes in a field.
Give some ashes to a friend who shared the sadness.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Your friend who had a sad memory.
Here's some ashes.
Like that's rude.
The is 4.7 11 million
fucking Twitter followers.
That's hilarious.
That shows you how Twitter is crazy.
Yoga on a whole has more than 4 million Twitter followers because she
used to fuck one of the best musicians ever.
Imagine.
Malarious okay,
this one.
Uh,
imagine what would happen to your room when you move away.
Imagine if there is anything in the room that you could take with you when you
die.
Oh,
shut the fuck up.
Shut the fuck.
How many retweets,
how many retweets?
Call your answer phone every day and complain and Moan about your life and
people around you.
Listen to the tape and the end of the year.
What?
Wow.
She doesn't even know how to say voicemail.
Call your answer phone.
That's not an answer.
Phone dummy.
It's God damn voicemail.
What planet are you live in?
You can't agree to the same descriptives.
Could that be a translation thing?
Maybe Watch,
she speaks English well,
sort of.
She speaks,
she's been around.
She's been speaking as long as I've been alive.
Yeah,
but people never really fully grab it if they didn't,
you know,
I don't understand how people could be in this country for so long and
communicate with like I have people in my life that I know that work in certain
places that I visit that speak Spanish mostly.
Yeah.
And I've been communicating with them for years and they still don't know how to
talk English.
I've met the like,
how hard is it man?
Is it that fucking hard?
My daughter's four and I can talk to her.
I've known you for 15 fucking years.
I've been coming to this place and I still can't understand.
That exposes this thing we were talking about earlier,
but how when you're young you have a cape capabilities to learn that will never
be replicated again.
That's not true either because I know people that have picked up languages late
into their fifties and they're fucking awesome at it.
I know people,
there's always going to be outliers,
so I was going to be special people,
but the average immigrant is,
he's never going to sound like a fluent person who grew up here.
Yeah,
but that's mostly because they keep themselves in communities that are other
immigrants and they speak their native language and I know they don't attempt to
do it,
but if you immerse yourself in whatever culture is Spanish culture and want to
learn how to speak Spanish,
right.
I know people that have learned in their adulthood learn how to speak Spanish.
They speak perfect Spanish.
They just chose to do it.
It's not impossible to do.
It's like,
it's all just a matter of focus.
If you can get good at swimming into your thirties very few.
You'll see very few Western people learn how to speak Asian languages.
Right.
But I think that is more of a time and interest thing than it is of an ability.
Yeah.
I sense a challenge here.
I'm not doing it.
I have no time and I have no interest.
See,
I just sort of prove my point.
Well,
yeah,
but I don't know.
I think a lot of people like to walk around to and say,
Hey,
I learned another language and who's testing it?
I'm not testing their theory.
I'll go,
okay,
fine.
You can,
you can tell somebody you're hungry in another language.
Good.
Great.
Who's,
who's really patrolling that?
What does it commit?
Canadian comedian,
I don't know his name,
but uh,
he learned Chinese,
learned Mandarin.
It was,
and went to China and started doing standup in Chinese and there was a video
that they put online.
It was fascinating
because the white guy.
Yeah,
White Guy.
The accident was a main,
obviously,
I don't know whether or not he's saying they're right,
but the bloody tone child,
and he was talking like he was from China.
I'm sure.
I mean if you're going to put somebody in it into a test to figure out if
they're actually fluent in the language,
put him on a stage in front of a bunch of people and see if he can make them
laugh.
You know?
Like if,
if the guy was able to put that together,
I'd say he's probably pretty fluent.
Well,
I think it was also like a situation where he just recognized that there was a
big market that wasn't being tapped into it.
Right?
Like here's millions of people.
They have this new freedom now.
Billions.
Yeah.
Billion.
How many billions are in China's one?
At least one,
right?
At least one.
Yeah.
So all these people that don't have access to stand up comedy,
you know,
and their language really.
There's no such thing as Chinese standup comedy.
I wouldn't say there's no such thing,
but it's certainly not nearly as popular as English speaking.
Comedy isn't Canada.
So there's a lot of Goddamn Canadian comedian.
She's like,
if you wanted to learn stand up comedy and you wanted to perform it in Canada,
there's many,
many,
many venues.
Many places do it of course,
but there's also many comedians.
Whereas if you wanted to learn Chinese and just tap,
I mean maybe his motivational learning Chinese was totally unrelated to his
doing standup and Jamie might be just person.
Like my friend John was like super intro into languages.
He spoke five different languages.
He just loved learning languages and he would practice them with people that you
know,
spoke it.
It could be that,
but also it's like the amount of competition that you have over there.
It's probably none.
Yeah.
It doesn't help.
Advantage
usually advantage to being white over there in general.
I know a couple of buddies went over there to teach English in Korea mean it's
like you're a stud,
you know,
because you're the,
you're the guy.
You know what I mean?
You're the guy that they see on TV,
you know,
you're you,
you,
you're Tom Cruise for a minute.
Really?
Yeah,
because they're really homogenous society.
He's like,
you're walking around Japan,
you're not seeing this mixed,
this mix up of ethnicity that you have in North America.
We have,
we have a very strange cultural experience compared to the rest of the world.
Yeah,
that Kinda makes sense.
It kind of makes sense in the fact that there's so much content.
Again,
that gets distributed by Americans,
but that's also why it's really crazy.
And Korea where they,
the amount of people getting surgery to change their appearance to a western
appearance.
That's crazy.
Whew.
Boy,
we've gotten into it a few times on the podcast.
We won't get into it again cause he shared a bunch of links and a bunch of
images,
but it's apparently as popular as like braces and I don't like that people get
like some serious planning.
It's in India.
They trying to get lighter.
Yeah.
Well you know what they use in a lot of those,
um,
those places they use some sort of a,
an injection that a,
again,
chemical,
hold on a second.
I've said it before and I know what it is.
Halapens they do it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Lighter skin.
I forget what it's called.
It's actually also an amino or something like that.
Yeah.
But it's,
it's harmful.
Right?
Um,
it's,
it's actually a good thing for you.
It's like healthy.
Um,
if you take it like as a dietary supplement with the fuck is it called
Glutathione Glutathione,
which is a glutathione is what is it I'm originally used for,
I forget what it's originally used for,
but it's also been shown to aid in the body's absorption of alcohol.
So a Dr. Mark Gordon,
who had been on my podcast before told me that it would greatly decrease the
effect that alcohol has on your body.
That glue to thigh own ha helps in some way to digest alcohol.
It's an antioxidant and plants,
animals,
fungi and some bacteria,
uh,
preventing damage to important cellular components caused by reactive oxygen
species such as free radicals and peroxides.
So I'm somehow or another,
they inject this stuff into their body and it makes you think,
it makes you turn more pale and some,
some strange weather and stuff.
Michael Jackson was on,
I don't know what the fuck they do and actually have pills too.
I Dunno.
Skin whitening at home.
It was a video as a video,
how to Whiten your skin.
After eight weeks,
I managed to get my skin a few turns wider and also got rid of my freckles.
Whoa.
What else are you doing?
What are you doing to your eyes?
What you're doing?
Your fucking peel rain.
What's going on there?
I Dunno man.
It's like that's a,
that's a really far into the spectrum kind of scenario in which you can,
you can immediately see the western influence on the rest of the world in a
physical way.
Well,
how about people that Tan though?
What about people that get nutty and they,
they don't feel comfortable unless they're super,
Super Tan it.
That's,
is that how many people are into that?
A lot.
Yeah.
I remember that Tam Ladies Tanning.
Remember that Tan lady that was on TV?
She was like insanely dark.
Yeah,
so it took her daughter tanning and burned.
Her daughter do.
Is there such a thing as white people trying to look like some other race?
There's such a thing as white people trying to look darker for sure.
Well darker,
but you know what I mean.
Like I surgeries or I fuck I guess everyone,
well Brazilian guy just got an operation recently to look Korean.
Get the fuck out of here.
Yeah,
it was big news piece.
Wow.
But people on the planet,
I guess every for sure everyone's tried something only they tried it.
There's probably a forum about it.
Reddit sub.
Yeah.
Nasty look.
People are,
and also it's like what we're talking about before,
there's a lot of people that are just not,
they're not comfortable with who they are.
Yeah.
So they think that maybe if I look Korean I'd feel better.
Maybe I suppose a few shades whiter,
I'd feel better.
Right.
I think it gets particularly strange or interesting when it's a huge group of
people that are doing it right.
I mean when you have,
when you have a trend,
when it sort of changes.
Yeah.
And that's also what we're talking about.
It's like where's the content coming from?
Most of it's from the West.
So this,
these,
these features is Brad Pitt face that you're seeing on your big screen over and
over again.
And sort of making you want,
why are my eyes so small?
But the physical manifestation of influence,
the physical manifestation.
Wow.
But isn't it all the physical manifestation of influence when it comes to like
cultural ideas?
What do you choose to wear?
What are your clothes?
How about you put a plate in your lip?
Who,
how'd that get started?
How you got to bone through your nose?
Who the fuck else has a violence with their nose?
Is that your thing?
You the only guy?
No,
it's a tradition.
Well,
were the fun.
We look great.
We have bones in their nose.
You do not look great.
Come here.
Yeah.
So ultimately we all do things because of other people and what they're doing.
Well there was
thing on this television show where this guy was going to,
this guy was going to Africa and um,
he was visiting with these people that are regularly being around crocodiles and
they have these markings that they see the scar there skin in the form of
crocodile crocodile ridges and they have across their bodies really crazy shit.
And they,
they sort of mimic the skin of a crocodile.
Whoa.
Yeah.
What's the,
what?
Just what I'm coming of age thing with men and they do this and it sort of
represents strength and they cover themselves.
This,
these crocodiles scars.
It was so weird to look at these key Lloyd scars all around this guy's body and
this somehow or another become a part of their culture,
like war paint or weird facial pain or how about what we think of as normal when
a woman wears ridiculous lipstick and blue colored eyeliner and you know,
Lash to say,
I'm happy as hell that that's not us.
We don't have sex.
If you've ever watched it going down
like a fucking assault,
like a woman's getting beat up by her makeup,
your watch going down,
Bro,
it's hard to watch.
It is.
You can't just get out of bed and get to your shit.
Can't just move on with your life.
Like I put no thought.
I mean,
not,
no.
I mean I got to look in the mirror and make sure I'm not fucked up or for some
reason,
you know,
but the idea that there's preparation just to leave the house,
facial preparation and
women,
if they don't have their makeup on and another girl is around and she has her
makeup on,
they get like upset.
Oh my gosh,
how am I fucking makeup on and put my makeup on?
You should've told me that she has her makeup on crazy colors.
Like from space.
We'll get her eyes.
She closes her eyes.
She see the heavens.
She's winning in her eyelids.
Eight goddammit.
Her skin is perfect.
It's covered in fucking powder.
How is their skin colored?
Powder all over.
Yeah.
We lucked out,
man.
We let her nails.
We lucked out in all kinds of areas except how about urinating?
Awesome.
Except we dine wore more often.
We,
uh,
we have,
jobs are far more dangerous.
We're more likely to be murdered.
Right.
A lot of shit that's not so hot.
Yeah,
no.
You know what?
You know what else you hadn't that you have to be tough to a degree.
Like you think so,
well let's,
let's put it this way,
but let's say,
uh,
growing up,
you know,
there's going to be circumstances in which you could be physically threatened
and that's socially acceptable for a woman.
It's really never,
I mean,
unless you being threatened by another woman or,
or unless it's like an actual crime,
but if two boys who are 10 years old decided to Duke it out,
it's not a crime.
You know?
I think that's a lot of it is there's a real problem with people and,
and violent interactions that could,
a lot of the problems could be resolved with the introduction of martial arts
early in people's lives,
right?
Like the amount of actual violence that you see,
like
other than sparring and an actual martial arts environment is almost
nonexistent.
It's very,
very rare and rare.
Jim,
we see people arguing or fighting most of the time.
It's just,
you're,
you're getting it all out.
You getting it on your system.
I agree with that.
But I think what maybe what I should have said was this idea that a man needs to
stick up for himself.
Yeah.
Like all,
all this,
the,
the dish Chicago stuff I was talking about earlier,
they had like 50 murders last month or something crazy.
And I'm guarantee they're all men shooting then.
Yeah,
but that's a poverty crime,
gangs,
drug.
What has the both sexes exist there?
Yeah,
that's true.
Well there's actually a lot of girls that are involved in gang crime as well.
Chicago,
I'm sure.
But it's a big article recently about this one girl died and she was like 19
years old and she had all these photos of her online with guns holding up guns
and shit making gangs.
I'm sure that's there too.
But I think the tough guy thing,
it's definitely a thing.
It is.
It's a jungle out there.
We're out of time.
Dude.
Will fucking kill the yeah.
Hey,
thanks again.
Lots of thank you both things we did today where for really fantastic.
I can't wait on the smash it and it was fun to um,
to do podcasts with you again.
We've got to do this more often.
Time.
Never run out of shit to talk about.
Never.
Thanks to Squarespace.
Go to squarespace.com and use the code word Joe for a 10% off your first
purchase and for a free trial@squarespace.com the code word is Joe.
Thanks.
Also to our new sponsor,
untuckit untuckit.com u n t u C K,
I t.com.
Go there and use the Promo Code Rogan and get 10% off shipping is free both
ways.
Thanks also to on.com o.
N n.
I.
T use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
Much love you dirty bitches.
And we'll see you tomorrow,
mark.
Oh,
you were?
It's from the snoop Dogg.
Yeah.
Oh,
don't do that.